[musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement Arnaud
Mondbourg ? Ah non, j'ai j'aimerais que
Arnaud présente Olivier. Olivier
présente Arnaud. C'était une idée
d'Arnaud d'ailleurs.
C'est une bonne idée de [rires] comme ça
parce que ça ça permet de faire des
compliments à quelqu'un qu'on aime bien.
Olivier Luenziany est un ancien
industriel qui a dirigé des entreprises
industrielles chez Saint-Gobin
et qui que j'ai voulu embaucher quand
j'étais ministère de l'industrie comme
directeur de mon cabinet. Il a refusé
parce queil avait mieux à faire.
Et c'est l'homme qui sait tout de
l'industrie, la manière de la redresser
en France. Il a fait, pardon pour sa
modestie qui va être écorché, un rapport
à la demande du gouvernement de qui
était, je crois exprimé par la personne
de monsieur Bruno Lemire, ministre de
l'économie.
Ce rapport n'a pas été publié
et c'est donc Olivier qui a publié sous
forme d'un livre
réindustriation le défi d'une génération
qui est le rapport et que toute la
jeunesse
passionnée par la France ses problèmes
économiques et les solutions que nous
devrions porter ensemble devrai lire.
Et depuis, bon, Olivier est est
professeur au Conservatoire national des
arts et métiers, une grande école
d'ingénieur qui a formé les générations
de ceux qu'on fait la France et le reste
du monde à bout.
et il est l'homme qui m'a ébloui
lorsqu'il a travaillé la question de la
balance commerciale produit par produit
et il a identifié les points sur
lesquels on pouvait très facilement avec
j'allais dire un effort de 10 années
donc c'est deux deux mandats politiqu on
pouvait remonter le PIB de la France
voilà c'est pour ça que je j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui et S'il et je vais
terminer ces compliments
profondément sincères en disant que s'il
devait y avoir un ministre de la
réindustrialisation, quel que soit le
gouvernement, c'est lui qui devrait
l'être.
Lour de responsabilité Olivier.
[raclement de gorge]
Alors Olivier, il faut rendre
l'appareil.
Faut que je rende l'appareil.
Non, pas forcément.
Ah ben en tous les cas, un respect
sincère et une amitié sincère, ça c'est
une évidence. Moi j'ai rencontré Arnaud
comme homme politique, comme ministre.
C'était celui qui peut-être 10 ans avant
tout le monde a promu le made in France.
Euh a été capable de le rendre ouvert au
grand public he on se souvient tous de
cette couverture, la marinière et
cetera. Une une capacité de percussion
auprès de l'ensemble des Français pour
faire passer ce message qui à l'époque
est pas passé entièrement et puis 10 ans
après, on se rend compte combien il a
raison. Donc il y a il y a cet homme
politique engagé qui est en lui
visionnaire que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
avec une énergie absolument folle.
Souvenez-vous de la crise de 2012 et les
Monbourg Boys et girls qui étaient dans
les territoires là, les CRP qui
essayaient de redresser toutes les
boîtes qui tombaient avec une énergie
folle. J'ai aussi eu la chance de de te
rencontrer un peu à titre privé chez
toi.
Ça fait un peu ça fait un peu hommage
finèbre là.
Oh arrête,
je suis pas encore mort, vous m'avez pas
enterré.
Et là c'est c'est le papa que que j'ai
rencontré aussi. J'aime bien aussi
rencontrer des personnes et pas que des
hommes et des femmes politiques. Et puis
il y a l'entrepreneur aujourd'hui, celui
qui a décidé de passer de la vie
publique, politique à l'entreprise, qui
a découvert tout ce qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur d'une boîte. Qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un un bilan, un compte de
résultat de se faire financer la
discussion avec les banquiers et cetera,
la vérité vraie de de notre activité
économique. Ça c'est une belle trace
d'humilité aussi dans son personnalité
parce que Arnaud il a le verbe
flamboyant hein, on le connaît tous mais
aussi cette capacité de se remettre sur
le terrain et puis aujourd'hui aussi son
émission hein sur BFM où il nous
réintroduit tous les sujets qui l'ont
animé depuis 10 ans et qui essaent
toujours de les diffuser. Voilà, une
trajectoire d'un d'Arnaud qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup impressionné dans sa
diversité aussi.
OK. Les gars, vous connaissez la chaîne
YouTube ?
Bien sûr,
Arnaud.
Heureusement.
La votre interview préférée, si s'il y
en avait une à extraire, à conseiller à
notre communauté,
une interview préférée.
Ouais. celle où vous vous êtes régalé,
vous avez appris des trucs où on est
vraiment rentré en profondeur, où on a
challengé, où vraiment c'était
nécessaire pour le pays.
J'y vais moi, c'est Bréchet, celle de
Brchet.
Yve Bréchet extraordinaire, un
bourguignon,
c'est vrai,
un de chez nous et on embrasse Yve
Brchet au euh ancien au commissaire à
l'énergie atomique.
Exactement. Quelqu'un de brillantissime.
Arnaud,
moi j'aurais mis Proglio parce que ça a
été le patron de DF patriote
qui a euh défendu euh l'héritage de
Marcel Boiteteux, c'est-à-dire de ceux
qui ont fait euh de DF cet outil
permettant à la France d'être, si on ne
l'avait pas abîmé, d'être puissante dans
le monde agressif qui est maintenant
au-dessus de nous.
Bien, aujourd'hui vous allez faire les
gentils flics, je vais faire le mauvais
flic. Euh je ne crois pas du tout à la
réindustrialisation française pour des
question d'énergie à bon marché. Je
pense que la France est en danger de
mort. Je pense que la la France va être
annihilée par des décisions politiques
qui ont ruiné notre pays. Je pense que
la dette est devenue insupportable et je
pense qu'on maintient la stabilité du
pays, la stabilité sociale du pays par
un effet de manche de dette.
Euh je vais vous demander à chacun de me
dresser les cinq plus grosses menaces
que vous avez identifié pour les cinq
prochaines années. Les cinq plus grosses
menaces pour notre pays. Olivier,
cinq plus grosses menaces en tout
d'abord hein, la réindustrialisation, tu
y crois peut-être pas mais c'est
absolument indispensable.
Un pays qui ne produit pas est un pays
qui n'est pas souverain, qui n'a pas la
liberté de décider de son destin
collectif. Un pays qui ne produit pas
est un pays qui n'a pas de cohésion
sociale et territoriale parce que c'est
bien de faire des services à haute
valeur ajoutée. Il se concentre dans les
métropoles. On a des superbes métropoles
d'équilibre, il faut en être fier mais
on l'a fait au dépend de ce que
j'appelle les territoires de
sous-préfecture et ça nous a sauté au
visage. Ça s'est appelé les gilets
jaunes. On en reparlera parmi les
menaces qui sont et le troisième point,
il y a des gens qui peuvent débattre,
c'est que si on veut réduire notre
empreinte environnementale, il faut la
maîtriser. Et quand on a délocalisé
notre production, on a très
hyprocritement délocalisé aussi nos
pollutions ou notre empreinte
environnementale. Donc c'est même pas si
rationnellement on pourrait arriver à la
conclusion qu'on peut pas
réindustrialiser.
C'est même pas je dirais un truc
rationnel. C'est une conviction
profonde. Il faut avoir la foi pour le
faire. Il faut réindustrialiser.
Maintenant, les menaces, elles sont
derrière ça. Euh, la première, cohésion
sociale. Si on continue à concentrer la
richesse autour des métropoles, on a un
véritable problème de fracture
territoriale. On a eu la fracture
sociale il y a quelques années dans le
paysage politique. Là, elle nous a sauté
au visage une première fois. On n rien
changé à la donne. Les cahiers de
doléance des gilets jaunes sont restés
lettrre morte. la répartition de la
valeur ajoutée qu'on doit refaire entre
les métropoles et ces territoires-là ne
fonctionne pas. Donc ça c'est le premier
risque. Le deuxième risque pour moi
c'est un risque de dépendance accru et
approfondi. On a parlé des terres rares,
on parle des cloud et des données, mais
il y a plein de catégories de produits
sur lesquels on est dépendant à plus de
80 à 90 %. Alors, on n'est peut-être pas
à 100 % mais à ce niveau-là, si celui
qui détient la source des données d'un
côté, des terres rares de l'autre, des
puces électronique du troisè, des
médicaments, des antibiotiques, des
choses aussi simples que ça, si celui
qui détient la source il coupe le
robinet, on est à genoux. Donc ça pour
moi c'est la deuxème la deuxième menace.
La troisème menace, j'irai peut-être pas
jusqu'à 5, tu m'en excuseras, c'est que
on est à la veille d'élection
présidentielles, on voit les partis qui
commencent à mouliner des programmes.
Moi, je suis extrêmement triste et je
trouve que c'est une menace. Je ne vois
pas de projet de société émerger.
C'estàd OK, ma spécialité c'est
l'industrie, les politiques
industrielles, c'est une verticale. Tu
pourrais parler du logement, tu peux
parler de l'éducation, de la santé. Si
tu veux faire une politique industrielle
verticale, il faut l'accrocher quelque
part. Il faut qu'il y ait un clou, faut
qu'il y ait un projet de société sur
lequel tu dis je branche cette politique
là. Un outil productif, ça sert un
projet de société. Moi, je les vois pas
et je pense que c'est la troisième
menace que j'ai envie de citer et puis
je laisserai Arnaud compléter.
Arnaud, l'action sort du rêve.
Franchement, moi je ne suis pas du tout
pessimiste.
Euh pourtant, il y a des raisons de
l'être objectives.
Pourquoi ? Quelles sont les raisons
objectives ? Bah, on a un système
politique européen et national qui est
une catastrophe. Je parle du système,
c'est les décisions qui sont prises sont
décision de suicide.
Donc évidemment, tous ceux qui sont un
peu lucides euh s'aperçoivent que on va
vraiment descendre encore si tout ça
continue.
Euh l'économie telle qu'elle est elle
est aujourd'hui en en situation
difficile pour ne pas dire en
capilotade,
70000 faillites par an, c'est le record
supérieur battu
de des années de la grande récession
2008 de 2009. On était à 65000, nous on
est passé derrière, je me souviens, on
était à 60000, on se battait là 70000,
pas de problème. Tout va bien, le
ministre est content, le chômage
paraît-il baisse ? Incroyable. Bon, donc
un aveuglement collectif, euh les
niveaux
de destruction des biens communs,
j'appelle par exemple le prix de
l'électricité. C'est un bien commun.
Pourquoi ? Parce que l'électricité,
c'est la sève de l'économie. Donc on a
construit grâce aux générations
précédentes plan mes messe la suite.
D'ailleurs transpartisans hein c'est
droite gauche qui ont compris que le
nucléaire nous a ferait un avantage
comparatif, compétitif, considérable
nous permet d'avoir une une énergie bon
marché qui nous permet d'être industriel
et agricole. Bon productif et
compétitif. Et bien ça on l'a abîmé. On
l'a abîmé par des décisions là encore
suicidaires, nationales et européennes.
L'entrée dans le marché européen tel que
euh ils l'a font dysfonctionner nous
place en situation d'affaiblissement.
Rien de tout cela n'est irréversible.
Rien de tout cela. Et il n'est pas vrai
qu'à chaque fois on nous fait le
chantage du frexit. Si vous ne voulez
pas de ceci de l'Europe, c'est que vous
êtes antieuropéen et vous allez donc
sortir. Rien du tout. Que Néni. En
vérité il y a un moment on va faire un
reset. Alors, c'est un mot anglais,
pardon. [grognement] Une remise à plat
des relations entre les Étatsmembres et
l'Union européenne. Ce moment approche
parce qu'on ne peut pas continuer à
avoir euh les attaques droite douanières
trumpistes contre notre économie. plus
l'invasion industrielle chinoise qui est
en train de détruire littéralement
l'industrie automobile allemande. La
nôtre est en numéro 2 sur la liste et ne
pas réagir. Madame Van Derleon d'un côté
toute seule va signer le Turnberry de
sur le golfe de monsieur Trump. Elle se
met à genoux, elle signe à droite notre
asserissement. Alors, résumons. 15 euh
vous nous mettez euh 15 % de droit de
douane plus euh les 15 % de diminution
du dollar, ça fait 30 % de matraquage.
Et nous, aucune réciprocité. Vous voulez
notre épargne, vous allez nous pomper
notre ép, il nous pompe déjà notre
épargne. Ce sont les les épargnants
européens et français qui financent la
tech qui vient aujourd'hui pomper
l'économie et la valeur de de de l'une
des entreprises européennes et qui
rachète nos start-ups pour les embarquer
aux États-Unis et les détruire. Donc ça,
on se laisse encore faire. Et en plus,
on doit leur acheter du gaz à un prix
prohibitif après nous avoir fait
sanctionner le gaz russe.
Voilà, ça c'est signé toute seule. Et
pendant ce temps-là, les Chinois
avancent. Alors, les Américains, ils
jouent aux échecs, les Chinois, ils
jouent au jeu de go, ils nous
encerclent. Donc comme ça, on est bien,
on est bien muni. Donc tout ça, la
rébellion contre l'Union européenne,
contre système politique, en effet
aujourd'hui est lourde dans d'abord
parce qu'il y a un vieux divorce et nous
savons que nous avons besoin de l'Union
européenne.
Donc le sujet c'est pas pour ou contre
l'Europe, c'est une Europe tournée vers
la protection contre les menaces
extérieures et de moins en moins
intrusive vis-à-vis de l'intérieur.
C'est-à-dire bah donc on va leur dire
écoutez vos histoires de
marché de l'énergie on va abandonner et
c'est pas grave car ça n'empêchera pas
de se vendre de l'électricité comme
avant. Le marcher sera toujours
interconnecté mais l'Europe est a un
pivot énergétique qui est la France.
C'est le pivot technique qui alimente
tous les autres et c'est le perdant
économique. Nous ne pouvons plus nous
laisser faire. Donc ça c'est des
décisions nationales qui emporteront des
remises à plat dans la répartition des
compétences entre l'Union européenne et
la France. Alors moi, j'ai coutume de
dire que tout ça n'est pas irréversible
pour une raison simple, c'est que
d'abord c'est le bon sens, deuxièmement
c'est l'intérêt national et que nous
sommes dans une situation si difficile
que nous avons besoin de retrouver de
l'oxygène pour respirer à nouveau.
Il y a dans la France des ressources
extraordinaires. Moi, je vois partout.
Les gens sont déprimés collectivement et
combatifs individuellement.
Désespoir collectif, bonheur individuel.
On voit ça partout.
Mais on n' pas les débouché pour faire
surgir des décisions intelligentes. Vous
avez aujourd'hui à la tête de l'État une
administration qui est peuplé de gens
très intelligents et qui prennent
collectivement les décisions les plus
stupides et antinationales qui puissent
exister. Donc on a besoin, je crois de
se dire ces choses-là. Voilà. Et donc ça
c'est les menaces, elles sont d'abord
liées à notre désorganisation. Nous ne
sommes pas capables de prendre les
bonnes décisions pour nous-mêmes
conformément à nos intérêts et d'avoir
la sagesse de mettre à distance celles
qui nous mettent en en grave difficulté.
Voilà ce que je dirais aujourd'hui.
Les cinq menaces ont été verbalisées.
Pas tout à fait, il y en a beaucoup
d'autres. Alors, les menaces, j'aime
bien l'idée des menaces intérieures
parce que elles viennent de nous-même,
hein, de nos propres faiblesses.
[grognement] Bon, le financement par la
dette sociale
à crédit de notre train de vie ne peut
pas continuer.
Voilà, c'est tout. Le niveau des
retraites,
les retraites sont indexées sur
l'inflation. Les salaires ne le sont pas
par le SMIC. Donc, les actifs eux
prennent l'inflation et les retraités
sont protégés.
alors qu'ils sont propriétaires de leur
logement, qu'ils ont finalement
eux-mêmes n'ont pas les contraintes que
les actifs ont à subir. Donc
aujourd'hui, vous avez avoir vous avez
une crise intergénérationnelle qui est
en train de d'exploser. D'ailleurs, on
pourrait mettre en rapport la crise
démographique avec la façon dont
l'Occident a privilégié les seigneors.
Donc maintenant, vous avez des actifs
qui commencent à se mettre en grève, qui
disent à quoi bon travailler,
pourquoi faire, à quoi vont faire des
enfants, pourquoi [grognement] faire ?
Donc on a à trouver le compromis social
entre les générations pour établir une
forme d'équilibre. Donc ça ça fait
partie de la dette sociale. Quand vous
avez une feuille de paix, vous avez 100
€ de salaire, vous avez 28 € qui partent
sur les retraites.
Pourquoi le budget de l'État donne
l'impression d'être obèse avec des
résultats aussi minables dans
l'éducation nationale et la santé ?
Pourquoi ? Parce que faut payer les
retraites
et c'est les impôts qui les payent parce
que les actifs dans la fonction publique
ne peuvent pas subvenir aux besoins des
retraités. Il faut donc une subvention
d'équilibre. Donc vous avez des budgets
qui sont obérés par ça. Donc il faut
qu'on [grognement] accepte l'idée 1. On
va être obligé, on va avoir la double
peine parce qu'on a la chute
démographique qui fait que en 2070, il y
aura 1,4 actif pour un retraité. Donc
presque un point. en 70, donc 100 ans
avant donc comme moi j'avais
8 ans, on était 3 et demi pour 1. Donc
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça. Donc
il va falloir traiter ce problème. Donc
il faut être beaucoup plus nombreux à
travailler. Il manque un million
d'emplois donc faut réindustrialiser.
C'est ce que disait Olivier. Il faut en
plus travailler plus parce que si on
travaille pas assez bah comment on va
faire pour nourrir les autres ? Et puis
il va falloir à un moment qu'on accepte
la discipline
au fil du temps. Ça se fera pas tout de
suite mais il faut avoir l'intelligence
de dire la dette n'est pas en soit
mauvaise comme le cholestérol. Il y a le
bon et le mauvais. La dette il y a la
bonne et la mauvaise. La mauvaise dette
c'est celle qui finance le train de vie.
La bonne dette c'est celle qui investit
qui permet d'investir infrastructure
éducation
et qui permet d'avoir des revenus en
contrepartie. [grognement] Je rebondis
sur Arnaud avant de rebondir sur toi.
Olivier euh Ursula Vlenlen, elle euh
elle tropasse pas un petit peu ses
pouvoir là ?
Alors merci de poser cette question
inattendue
mais tout à fait euh nécessaire.
1 madame Veryen, comme la quasi totalité
des institutions européennes agissent
hors traité. C'est-à-dire qu'ils sont en
situation ce qu'on appelle chez les
juristes ultravies. Qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ? C'est une espèce de
barbarisme qui est très précis. C'est
vous êtes hors de vos compétences. Le
parlement légifère sur des tas de sujets
qu' il n'a pas le droit de légiférer. La
Commission européenne alors elle elle
est invasive et intrusive. Elle régit la
vie des des Européens toute la journée
surtout et n'importe quoi. La queue des
casseroles, la gomme arabique, je ne
sais quoi, les élastiques pour jouer
dans les cours de récréation et cetera
et cetera. D'où le sentiment de
d'intrusion permanent espèce de
fabrication de normes à getue qui fait
que 65 % des décisions, des lois, des
règlements sont d'inspiration européenne
sont pas du tout décidé par nos élus.
Voilà, c'est fait par un truc bizarre
avec des compromis dans une chambre
noire ou une boîte noire qu'on arrive
jamais à décrypter et ouvrir. Et puis
surtout euh il y a en Allemagne, ça
c'est un point intéressant, les
Allemands, ils ont mis un système de
protection contre ces excès de pouvoir,
ces espèces de dérives
extra traité des institutions
européennes.
Ils ont un tribunal constitutionnel qui
est absolument rigide et heureusement
pour eux qui est de c'est le tribunal
constitutionnel de Cars R qui fait
respecter la constitution allemande
contre les institutions européennes et
écarte tous les textes qui sont hors
traité en disant la Constitution
allemande dans sa souveraineté doit être
respectée. C'est un traité. Donc il n'y
a pas un pouvoir puisque c'est un
pouvoir délégué depuis les États-membres
vers un traité qui est un accord
international. Il n'y a pas de
légitimité à ce que le droit européen
passe son temps à piétiner notre
constitution. Chez nous en France, nous
avons trois juridictions : Conseil
d'État, Cour de cassation, Conseil
constitutionnel. Aucune d'entre elles ne
fait respecter les traités européens. Et
donc, vous avez le Conseil d'État qui se
permet d'écarter euh les demandes et ça
a été fait par Jean Castec, il était
premier ministre. Il a demandé
l'application
de la Constitution, c'est-à-dire le
droit pour la France de préférer ses
lois nationales plutôt que les décisions
européennes. Et le Conseil d'État a dire
bah non non.
[grognement]
Et c'était dans une affaire de sécurité
intérieure puisque ça concernait euh le
décryptage par les services de sécurité
euh de l'ensemble des des euh des des
données
des données cryptées, des réseaux des
des données cryptées,
des euh systèmes comme de de
communication qui servaient à la
délinquence bien entendu. Donc on a un
problème d'ailleurs, un jour le Conseil
d'État benoîement m'a demandé de venir
parler de souveraineté. Ah ben je dis
bah vous tombez bien, vous êtes les
auteurs des atteintes à la souveraineté.
C'est vous par votre jurisprudence
[souffle coupé] et la Courte cassation
mais essentiellement le Conseil d'État
qui est très actif sur le sujet qui
pensait que l'intégration européenne
c'est l'abandon de toute décision euh
venue de la souveraineté nationale. Donc
là je leur ai dit vous allez avoir un
retour de bâton extrêmement grave. Donc
préparez-vous, ça va secouer. Il faut se
prépar et j'ai d'ailleurs pont je leur
envoyé une note que j'ai rendu publique.
Elle a été rendue publ par la fondation
de Jean-Pierre Chevinement respublica
parce que si ceux qui veulent s si si se
se s'y référer. Alors ils n'ont pas
voulu en faire état parce que ils ont le
comme toujours si vous voulez la
souveraineté c'est un discours
cosmétique mais quand il s'agit de
protéger nos intérêts, il y a plus
personne.
Juste avant de redonner la parole
Olivier, en deux mots, on qualifie cette
attitude de quoi ? C'est de la
forfaiture ? C'est quoi ?
Non, c'est c'est une culture
pas de couille, pas d'embrouille. C'est
une culture,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la culture de la
construction européenne.
Je vais vous dire pourquoi.
Les Allemands, ils construisent
l'Allemagne. Les Italiens, l'Italie, les
Espagnols, l'Espagne. La France, elle
construit l'Europe, mais elle est toute
seule. Donc c'est elle la variable
d'ajustement. Et nous avons une corte de
haut fonctionnaires qui d'ailleurs
passent leur vie Bruxelles dans leur
carrière, dans leur vie et dans leur
culture. Ils considèrent qu'ils sont la
l'avant-garde éclairée de l'intelligence
nationale et ils pensent que être
européen,
c'est défendre l'intérêt national. C'est
pas vrai. Et donc ça, on peut pas leur
en vouloir. On peut pas en faire des
criminels. On peut juste se dire qu'on
est qu'on a une élite qui n'a pas
compris le sens de l'histoire.
OK. Cette élite française là, est-ce que
vous avez regardé qui est-ce qui les
finance ? Avec qui ils sont connectés ?
Est-ce qu'ils sont connectés avec des
réseaux américains atlantistes ? Est-ce
qu'ils ont bénéficié des largesses ? On
s'est compris. Alors oui, alors moi j'ai
pas de vision euh j'allais dire euh euh
de défense nationale.
Non mais j'ai pas de protection pas
connaissance ni de vision. C'est quand
quelqu'un défend quelque chose, je
considère que c'est qu'il le pense.
Peut-être qu'il est acheté. Je n'ai pas
de vision de généralisé de la haute
administration.
Vous êtes pas un peu naïf ?
C'est possible. J'en accepte la mauvaise
augure. Il m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
de l'être et je préfère le rester pour
pouvoir continuer à mener sincèrement le
combat. Mais je dois vous dire que bien
sûr, moi ce que je vois si vous voulez
c'est que euh il y a il y a un entre
soit hein, il y a une endogamie, ça
c'est certain et puis il y a une espèce
d'absence de diversité culturelle. Moi
quand j'étais à Beril, passait ma vie à
diversifier. Je disais à la direction du
trésor, il faudrait qu'on ait des
économistes, c'est des universitaires.
C'est l'université c'est la franchise
universitaire, c'est la liberté de
penser. Et évidemment, nous on nous
disait "Non, mais ça c'est des postes
réservés à à des haut fonctionnaires qui
ont fait ceci, qu'on fait cela et
cetera, qui ont le diplôme de ceci et de
cela, qui sont dans tel grand corps, qui
viennent de l'ENAT, qu'on fait bon très
bien." Je leur dis peut-être mais on a
besoin d'avoir comme par exemple dans
l'administration américaine ou les
administrations européennes euh une
espèce de melting pot intellectuel pour
que le gouvernement soit éclairé par
autre chose que des gars qui répètent
leurs polycopiers depuis qu'ils ont 25
ans et qui se rengorgent de leur propre
diplôme. Les diplômes ne nous
intéressent pas. Ce qui nous intéresse,
c'est l'expérience, le terrain, la
pensée libre, la confrontation dans les
symposiums universitaires mondiaux. Donc
moi j'ai dit moi je veux des prix Nobel
à telle de la direction du trésor.
Voilà et on m'a dit ah bah oui mais
c'est des postes réservés à au magistrat
de la cour des comptes. Ah alors dans ce
cas-là amen
vous avez compris les ministres passent
l'administration se maintient
et la France
et c'est ce qu'il pensent et la France
et ça c'est vous qui l'avez dit.
Je trouve que la rime est riche.
La rime est riche. La balance
commerciale on en est où ? Alors
Olivier, la balance commerciale, elle
est pas bonne notamment en bien et elle
elle est structurellement pas bonne
depuis le milieu des années 2000. 50
milliards. L'Italie, elle est à plus 100
milliards sur les biens, hein. L'Italie,
elle était excédentaire en 2000. Elle
était excédentaire.
Oui, elle était excellentaire en 2000.
Elle a vraiment basculé structurellement
au milieu des années 2000 et depuis
c'est c'est l'indicateur majeur hein
pour moi de la santé l'économie d'un
pays. Alors on fait des calculs savants
avec les entrées des dividendes des
grands groupes parce qu'on a des très
grands groupes qui ont investi
énormément à l'extérieur et qui font des
rentrées. [grognement] On fait des
calculs aussi avec les services mais
encore une fois on parle de souveraineté
et il y a des services de souveraineté
indéiablement mais beaucoup de la
souveraineté est concentrée dans les
biens et là on a une balance qui est
structurellement déficitaire. En effet,
je voudrais rebondir sur ce qu'a dit
Arnaud. Je vais lui laisser la partie la
partie Europe. Moi, je voudrais parler
de l'incompréhension qu'il y a
aujourd'hui entre ce qui se passe dans
nos territoires avec des gens qui
veulent se battre et ce qui se passe à
Paris. Moi, je suis très très frappé.
Enfin, j'ai parlé de cette cette
question de cohésion territoriale, hein.
J'ai fait le tour de la France, j'ai
fait 50 villes, petites, moyenne pour
présenter le bouquin dont Arnaud a
parlé. Aujourd'hui, il y a de plus en
plus de la colère et de
l'incompréhension par rapport à une un
pilotage central. J'ai pas la verve de
Arnaud pour décrire ça avec les mêmes
mots que lui, mais il y a la même colère
que celle qui l'exprime entre l'Europe
et et enfin en tous les cas
l'incompréhension entre le niveau
européen et le niveau français. Et là
avec les territoires, moi c'est quelque
chose qui me marque véritablement. On a
une administration, une autre
administration qui pilote le pays en ne
comprenant pas ce qui se passe sur le
terrain tout simplement. Qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans les boîtes ? Qu'est-ce que
vivent les territoires ? Moi, il y a un
chiffre qui m'a marqué énormément, le
niveau de pauvreté des Français. Je
crois que le chiffre date d'il y a
quelques années. Un tiers des ménages
français ont moins de 100 € sur leur
compte en banque le 15 ou le 10 du mois.
Mais vous vous rendez compte comment
enfin c'est c'est une réalité terrible
sur l'état de santé économique de notre
pays. Où est-ce que c'est relayé dans
des grandes politiques ? Où est-ce qu'on
s'adresse ? À ces territoires qui
souffrent, à ces villes qui sont parties
en vrille économiquement, socialement et
voire politiquement. C'est qui ont plus
l'impression de partager un destin
commun avec la nation parce qu'on les a
laissé tomber, parce qu'on a laissé
tomber leur outil productif notamment.
Voilà un autre élément de cette
fragilité, de cette fracture que
mentionne Arnaud qui est celle entre les
territoires et la capitale et qui ne va
pas en se en se rétrécissant. Et là, je
partage aussi le constat de Arnaud.
C'estàd que il n'y a rien d'irrémédiable
là-dedans.
Non, mais tout le monde tout le monde a
le droit tout le monde a le droit de
mettre des lunettes rose les gars.
Je veux bien qu'il y a rien
d'irrémédiable. Je vois la capacité de
la France à aller sur les marchés de du
pétrole, du gaz contre des nations qui
ont les les gros, contre des nations qui
sont en terme géopolitique et et de de
partenariat diplomatique beaucoup plus
proche. Je vois la France n'ayant plus
de parole diplomatique, n'ayant plus la
capacité à aller discuter pour apaiser
les choses, être la troisème voix.
Je veux bien que vous ayez des lunettes
roses les enfants. Je vois Macron faire
des grands discours. J'ai vu Bruno
Lemire
se se
vanter qu'il ait sauvé la France. Euh je
je vois euh la dette, je vois les
marchés capables d'attaquer la dette
française, je vois une perte de
souveraineté totale et et et je je vois
personne être capable de dire
"Maintenant, ça suffit, on est français,
on va vous montrer ce que c'est être
français."
J'entends la proposition d'Arnaud en
disant "Nous sommes le hub énergétique.
Les Allemands ont voulu nous torpiller
notre nucléaire, on va les prendre et on
va les visser comme on sait faire."
J'allais dire en Bourgogne. Mais mais il
est il est temps de se réaffirmer les
enfants là. Qui voyez-vous dans le
gouvernement Macron ou le potentiel élu
à la prochaine élection présidentielle
capable de dire maintenant ça suffit ?
On a bien compris votre petit jeu. Les
Français sont réveillés. Si vous
commencez à nous chercher, on va vous
mettre des bâtons dans les roues. Les
Allemands, il va faire tout noir pendant
l'hiver. Il va faire 4 degrés à Berlin
et on va voir qui fait le malin avec ses
mixeuses à éolienne. Arnaud, je je
commence à m'énerver là.
Alors euh qui qui
Oui, comment comment
non ? Qui d'abord ? Qui
? Alors qui je le cherche encore ?
OK.
Bon, je la cherche
comment ou je la cherche ? Comment on
sait
comment ?
Comment on sait ? Il y a des décisions.
Moi, je voudrais je voudrais
qu'on regarde ce que c'est que des
décisions cohérentes où on mobilise
toute la société autour de la
reconstruction d'un appareil productif
digne de ce nom. C'estàdire qui nous
permett de nous nourrir, qui nous
permettent d'assurer notre liberté et
notre indépendance. C'est ça qu'il faut
faire. Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Ça consiste
en quoi ? Écoutez, c'est pas très
compliqué. D'abord, c'est une
mobilisation nationale. Donc c'est pas
le décret qui tombe d'en haut. C'est un
projet pour tout le monde.
Faut aller faut faut qu'on aille les
chercher.
Bah en fait c'est un projet où tout le
monde a quelque chose à apporter.
euh les syndicats, les entrepreneurs,
les les entreprises, les grandes
entreprises, les petites, les moyennes,
les TPE, tout le monde peut apporter ça.
Et les territoires, les élus euh et les
citoyens, les salariés, les
consommateurs, les distributeurs, tout
le monde peut s'y mettre. Mais pour ça,
il faut ordonner la volonté collective.
Faut qu'il y ait un leadership qui dise
bon bah on est faible, [grognement] on a
perdu de la substance, c'est pas on
n'est pas on a encore des grandes
ressources, on a de la puissance quand
même encore nous. On a l'aéronautique,
le nucléaire,
la métallurgie,
on a de l'automobile encore. Si si on
commence, on décide de se protéger enfin
contre l'invasion chinoise, franchement,
on est capable de rebondir parce que on
a de la force. Bon, quand on a dit ça
euh parce que on peut aussi euh pleurer
sur les renversé des 20 dernières
années, hein. Euh moi-même quand j'étais
au gouvernement, j'ai pleuré, hein, je
peux vous dire, hein. Et pas euh et
c'était difficile, hein. Bon, donc le
sujet c'est comment on fait ? Bah, c'est
pas compliqué, il va falloir réformer le
système financier et mettre du
protectionnisme dans le système
financier. C'est-à-dire dire "Bah,
écoutez, on a 3000 milliards de stock de
d'assurance vie, c'est nos fonds de
pension. Pour une fois, ils vont arrêter
de financer les États-Unis. Euh et la
tech, on va leur demander pour 5 % des
encours de financer les PME non côté.
Vous allez voir.
OK. Là, je t'envoie les fonds vautour,
je te fais attaquer ta dette qui s'est
fait dégradé sa note et là tu vas payer
quoi en intérêt de la dette ?
Bah d'abord euh
euh je suis pas sûr que la dette soit
une si grande vulnérabilité que ça si un
gouvernement décide de remettre la
France à niveau si c'est sa volonté et
qu'il a un chemin cohérent pour le
rendre crédible. Ça, moi je crois pas.
Pourquoi ? parce que euh la France n'est
pas dans une situation qui aujourd'hui
risquerait une attaque des marchés. Elle
risque juste l'aplexie budgétaire. Ça
c'est beaucoup plus grave. Écoutez-moi
bien. C'est beaucoup plus grave. C'est
ça veut dire que un gouvernement
aujourd'hui comme celui de monsieur le
cornu qui se retrouve avec 4 milliards
soit de perte de recett soit
d'augmentation d'opex militaire se
retrouve en situation de devoir refaire
son budget où il a déplacé 16 milliards
puisque c'était ça le budget non voté ou
voté à l'arrache avec des ordonnances au
[grognement] mois de février au lieu du
mois de décembre et ben les 16 milliards
déplacés son budget il est mort parce
que entre-temps la charge de la dette
elle a augmenté de 10 milliards. Donc
aujourd'hui
le vrai sujet
et d'autant que la restructuration de la
dette puisque arrive à échéance un
certain nombre d'emprunts d'obligation,
le taux est en train d'exploser, il est
multiplié par 3. C'est ça le sujet. Donc
là vous avez une explosion de l'intérêt
de la dette. Donc les marges de manœuvre
budgétaires sont en train de se
détruire, de rétrécir.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe après ? Bah si
vous avez par exemple un Mélenchon qui a
un programme absolument délirant parce
que euh j'ai regardé le programme
sérieusement euh 230 milliards de
dépenses nouvelles.
Là-dedans, vous avez 1 million d'emplois
publics créés.
Euh les recettes qui met en face, c'est
100 milliards euh de euh d'impôts
nouveaux, dont 80 milliards sur les
entreprises. Donc en fait, il va couler,
il va tuer la poule aux œufs d'or et il
va couler la France là pour le coup
parce que il n'y a aucune crédibilité
que d'abord il crée lui-même une impasse
donc il crée 100 milliards de déficit
chaque année. Donc en fait, c'est ce que
j'ai dit, si vous voulez couler la
France, bah faut voter Mélanchon au
premier tour. Elle est pas bien. Mais
alors là, on va l'achever, hein. C'est
le médecin de Molière qui pratique la
saignée pour guérir et qui l'envoie aux
obsèques. Bon voilà, c'est exactement
ça. Donc ça oui, ça c'est un désastre.
préfère en avertir. C'est un exemple de
désastre parce que vous prenez le
programme du Parti socialiste, il n'a
pas été chiffré mais moi je l'ai fait
chiffrer grâce à la puissance de Claude
qui est 5000 fois plus intelligent que
les assistants parlementaires réunis
dans la cour de récréation du Parti
socialiste. Et là, qu'est-ce qu'on voit
? On voit un mini mélon
pareil, des dépenses, des impôts.
Donc là, on a besoin quand même
de gens un petit peu sérieux. Et vous me
permettrez dire parce que moi je suis,
excusez-moi, je suis un peu le curé
des frqué qui a quitté l'église de la
social-démocratie.
Pourquoi ? Bah parce qu'elle abandonné
les gens. Je l'ai été, je l'ai bien vu
he abandonné les Français puis elle
abandonné la France, la nation, la
frontière, toutes ces choses très
importantes qui doivent animer tous les
partis politiques. C'est dans ce
cadre-là qu'on doit jouer. Donc
l'universalisme, c'est l'oubli de la
nation et de la France. Moi ça me va
pas. Oui, j'ai Imaginons, on a Arnaud
comme pointe de diamant. D'un coup de
baginguette magique, je lui fais
endosser le la fonction suprême de
président de la République.
Devriez pas, vous le regretteriez, même
s'il veut pas.
Mais si vous
c'est moi aussi [rires]
et la cheville ouvrière quand elle
entend ça, est-ce que c'est on peut
mettre ça en œuvre ? C'est-à-dire la
cohésion sociale. Après toutes ces
années de subordnation de vote en
passant de la droite à la gauche, je
suis le président du pouvoir d'achat,
votez pour moi. Je suis le futur
président qui va vous protéger. cette
subordination de vote par la dette qui a
entretenu pendant des années les gens
dans une sédation.
Quand on va réduire les budgets, l'État,
le futur président de la République va
se retrouver avec une contestation
sociale dingue. On voit les différentes
dotations de la police, de la
gendarmerie et même de l'armée augmenter
pour du contrôle social. Parce que quand
vous commandez x millions de grenades, x
millions de grenades de désencerclement,
c'est pas pour le 14 juillet ou
peut-être si ça va être pour le 14
juillet pour les Champs-Élysées.
Le président de la République, je vais
essayer de défendre Macron parce que
comme vous le savez, j'aime toujours
faire l'avocat du diable. Macron, il se
retrouve quand même avec potentiellement
des gilets jaunes sous stéroïdes qui ont
été matraqués. Maintenant, quand les
gens vont redescendre dans la rue,
[grognement] ils vont moins être
gentils. Ils vont arrêter de mettre un
uniforme gilet jaune, ils vont moins
être gentils. Quelle est la marge de
manœuvre d'un ministre des finances,
d'un président de la République quand il
y a eu en fait ce cette inertie, ce gras
qu'on a mis autour des gens de dette
pour les calmer, laisser dater. Est-ce
je pense que tu enfin on n pas la même
vision, on n' pas peut-être pas
rencontré les mêmes personnes. Alors
encore une fois la France est très
hétérogène mais quand tu vas encore une
fois dans dans les territoires, ceux qui
ont envie d'être productif un, la prise
de conscience de l'État actuel des
finances de l'État pas de la France
parce que la France est riche hein. 6600
milliards d'euros d'épargne des
Français.
Ouis mais ça on n'y touche pas. C'est
fiscalisé, c'est à nous, on n'y touche
pas.
Attends. OK. Non, mais je veux dire la
France elle-même comme pays, c'est un
pays riche qui a des moyens de relancer
les choses. Donc moi ce que ce que je je
trouve hein, ce que je ressens encore
une fois avec beaucoup d'humilité parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de de vision dessus
mais c'est que un les gens ont
parfaitement conscience de l'état actuel
des finances savent qu'ils vont devoir
se retrousser les manches. Et la
question c'est pas comment tu répartis
la pauvreté ou le le gâteau qui se
rétrécit par le mécanisme, c'est comment
tu recrées de la production et comment
tu recrées de la richesse
avec de l'énergie. Alors, notamment de
l'énergie, il y a pas que ça, mais on va
prendre un exemple. On a fait la startup
nation, on a mis des centaines et des
milliards d'euros sur la startup nation.
Alors, si on n pas le droit de dire ça
startup nation, on dit l'élevage de la
licorne magique.
L'élevage de la licorne [rires] magique,
si tu veux. Bon ben, il y a deux
licornes qui sont qui sont tombées.
C'est bien de faire des paris sur sur le
l'économie d'après-demain. Euh si on
avait mis 200 ou 300 millions d'euros
seulement, ça peut paraître beaucoup
mais à l'échelle de ce qu'on a mis dans
France 2030 sur les tissus des PME et de
et des ETI tous les ans, tu vois, depuis
10 ans.
On fait un élevage de cafard, c'est
bien.
Mais là, je te parle pas des gens qui
font de l'élevage de cafar, je te parle
des gens qui font de la mécanique de
précision, qui font de la plasturgie et
cetera. C'estàd des des business qui
sont existants, qui ont besoin de
trouver de l'investissement pour se
développer, qui ne présentent pas de
risque parce qu'ils connaissent leur
marché, connaissent leur technologie,
connaissent les compétences dont ils ont
besoin. Et si on avait fait ça, tu as un
potentiel de 400000 emplois en France
dans la production. Et c'est pas des
emplois collés au SUC, c'est des emplois
un peu au-dessus qui permettent de
financer notre charge sociale et cetera.
Donc tu as un vrai potentiel dans les
territoires de recréation de richesse.
Si tu veux répartir un gâteau qui se
rétrécit parce que d'un côté tu as la
dette, de l'autre côté tu as une
assistance, tu as une attente sociale
énorme. Oui effectivement tu vas vers
tension. Si tu te dis on va faire
grossir le gâteau et que tu expliques au
français comment on va le faire grossir
raisonnablement pas en visant 15 %
d'industrie dans le PIB dans 10 ans.
Parce que ça c'était juste illusoire. Si
on arrive déjà à 12 ou 13 %, si on crée
700 à 800000 emplois industriels dans 10
ans, on a déjà fait quelque chose qui
est super chouette pour notre nation. Et
c'est sur cette trajectoireelà, tu fais
grossir le gâteau et à ce moment-là, tu
as effectivement des arbitrages
difficiles à faire, mais tu donnes une
direction, tu donnes un projet et si tu
fais ça à mon avis, la colère dont tu
parles et que je constate aussi hein, tu
es capable non pas de la canaliser parce
que le terme est mauvais, mais de lui
donner une espérance, une direction qui
permet de nous remettre sur le chemin.
Mais si tu ne crées pas plus de richesse
dans ce pays, effectivement, on est
coincé par l'ensemble des contraintes
que tu que tu donnes. Et donc tu as ce
potentiel de notre tissu industriel qui
a été tenu ou écrasé pendant quelques
années. Puis on a eu ce cette folie sur
les licornes. Comment tu as dit ça ?
Enfin bref,
les vaches de la licorne magique. Le
haas de la licorne. Voilà.
La la la machine a aspiré des
subventions pour rien faire.
Donc on a on a on a ce potentiel là.
J'étais à j'étais à Montbéliard hier au
soir. On me racontait comment les
petites subventions entre guillemets
l'ordonné lors de France Relance avait
permis de moderniser ce cet outil
productif. Et quand on a basculé de
France-Rance à France 2030, les PMI,
elles y ont pas retrouvé plus
d'incitations à innover. Voilà. Donc
déjà là, tu as un potentiel énorme. Tu
as une épargne française 6600 milliards
d'euros. Je te demande pas de la taxer.
Je te demande qu'elle soit investie un
petit peu plus dans notre outil
productif. 2 ou 3 % de l'épargne. Si tu
prends que les fondes dont tu as parlé
Arnaud, ça fait 5 % parce que c'est la
moitié du total. Donc on est
parfaitement cohérent sur les chiffres.
Si tu mets ça et que tu l'injectes dans
l'outil productif, tu te fais une
trajectoire de réinvestissement et de
réindustrialisation qui te permet de
créer des emplois dans les territoires,
là où tu as ce problème de répartition
de la valeur ajoutée qui te permet
d'avoir un peu de souveraineté aussi. en
plus ça fera pas de mal en chemin et et
qui te donne cette création de richesse
supplémentaire pour financer ton système
social. Toutes ces solutions là, tu les
as, elles sont partagées entre les
organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales. Créer des
fonds, par exemple avec l'épargne
salariale qui financeraient non pas des
fonds basés au Luxembourg qui alimentent
des fonds américains et cetera, mais qui
financeraient des espèces de sparcasseur
régional, c'estàd banques régionales ou
des fonds régionaux pour ce tissu-là.
patronat et syndicat sont en faveur.
Donc allons-y. Pourquoi on y va pas ? Et
c'est là où tu as la question, qui
est-ce qui est capable de faire ça ?
Moi, je suis comme Arnaud, je ne sais
pas répondre mais je sais que ce pays
aujourd'hui est en train de construire
ce type de solution là. Les les les
organisations qui le font là, ce qu'on
appelle la société civile est d'accord
pour y aller. À partir du moment où tu
as cet espoir là, il y a un chemin à
suivre. Je t'ai parlé de l'épargne. Euh,
qu'est-ce qu'on pour la commande
publique. La commande publique. Là,
Arnaud a été un un visionnaire et il
s'est il s'est tapé la tête contre les
murs. Mais si on achetait en France
comme on achète en Allemagne et en
Italie et je te fais pas changer les
traités européens, tu fais 15 milliards
d'euros de plus pour le tissu industriel
français. On va sans sans tricher avec
les traités européens, juste en étant
intelligent sur la manière dont tu le
fais. 15 milliards d'euros, ça parlera
peut-être pas à tous nos auditeurs, mais
si on le met dans une perspective, c'est
à peu près un/3 de notre déficit
commercial, la commande en bien, 50
milliards en bien. D'accord ? Donc le le
la commande publique, si on l'orientait
patriotiquement dans le respect des
textes européens, sans se faire choper
par la police européenne, tu as là de
quoi réduire ton déficit commercial de
un/ers. C'est un levier macroéconomique
fantastique qu'onutilise pas. Pourquoi ?
Question de culture, il faut secouer le
système en effet. Mais là, la solution,
elle est connue.
Monsieur mon ministre,
quand vous voyez ça que il y a quand
même d'après Olivier, il y a quand même
quelque chose qui qu'on peut mettre en
œuvre rapidement. [soupir]
C'est ma conviction partager avec lui
depuis le début de cet entretien.
Mon monsieur mon ministre, pourquoi
c'est pas fait ?
Bah pour une raison simple. Par exemple
le la proposition d'Olivier Luenzi que
que j'approuve et que je trouve
parfaitement juste et efficiente
sur la mobilisation de l'Épargne France,
c'est une arme considérable. Tous les
pays n'ont pas cette arme. Nous avons
ça.
Donc c'est l'atour à partir duquel on
peut redémarrer.
C'est pas la peine de faire de la dette
là pour le coup, n'est-ce pas ? puisque
nous avons les actifs, c'est parce que
nous avons un système financier et un
système bancaire qui n'a pas été
réformé, qui ne fait pas son boulot, il
n'a pas été reconstruit pour financer la
réindustrialisation. Pourquoi ? Parce
que
il y a un petit sujet un de règles
européennes
de d'entre soi de l'administration
économique et du système bancaire et
puis les fonds sont devenus aussi des
outils de prédation pour les les
intérêts étrangers.
Donc si on avait un système bancaire qui
avait financé, on aurait moins de fonds
euh en fonds propres qui viennent
prendre des du capital, enfin investir
du capital mais qui en fait
s'installe et qui déménage notre
économie par petit bout. Donc on a raté
plutôt on a jamais voulu mettre à
l'ordre du jour parce que les intérêts
de la banque dans notre pays domine
l'administration économique, le MDEF et
un certain nombre de de de positions.
J'ai bien compris, vous savez, on le
sait. Donc là, il y a un petit sujet un
petit sujet de qui dirige le pays.
Voilà. Donc là euh moi je je suis
surpris parce que je suis allé voir un
ancien ministre qui s'appelle Éric
Lombard pour l'alerter pour lui pour
défendre cette proposition. Je lui dit
pourquoi tu fais pas ça hein ? Pourquoi
? Il m'a dit écoute Ouais Bruxelles,
ceci cela. Il était de bonne volonté.
Mais euh [grognement] ce qui ce qu'il a
ce qu'il m'a dit, il m'a dit "J'ai
regardé la migration de notre épargne.
Elle part dans des conditions
scandaleuses aux États-Unis financer la
tech et surtout au lieu de financer la
France, c'est notre argent. Et surtout,
dit-il, mon prédécesseur, il parlait
d'un certain Bruno Lemire, avait
organisé ce qu'on appelait le fond tibi,
du nom d'un polytechnicien qu'il avait
nommé, qui s'appelle Philippe Tibi, qui
était chargé de flécher amicalement, de
façon incitative mais non contraignante
les la collecte de l'assurance vie vers
des fonds qui devaient normalement
financer les PME dont parle Olivier.
Résultat totalement bidon et c'est Éric
Lombard qui me l'a dit. Je dis mais on
le sait ça. Donc qu'est-ce que vous
attendez pour faire une loi pour
contraindre là où on a essayé de parler
à l'oreille de la finance hein. C'était
c'était gentil. Faut plus être gentil.
Donc là les réformes du système bancaire
et les réformes de la mobilisation de
l'épargne et de laallocation des
ressources doivent changer. Il n'y a pas
de patriotisme dans la finance, il n'y
en a pas.
Et le système bancaire est il a il a
[grognement] quitté le terrain à part
les réseaux de banque mutualiste. tout
le reste a quitter le terrain
et et en plus enfin ce qui est alors il
y a question de l'institution mais
est-ce que les Français derrière ils
perdraient parce que tu vas dire OK
aujourd'hui on a une épargne on la met
sur des fonds ils vont de la tech il te
livre du 15 % et cetera c'est non ça
c'est ce qu'ils affichent je suis bien
d'accord avec toi en fait quand tu
regardes comme c'est des montages à
étage toi quand tu es un ménage qui met
5000 € 3000 € sur ces investissements là
tu as deux fois moins en taux donc tu es
plutôt à 7 % quelque chose comme ça hein
si tu peu et après l'attente, on a fait
un sondage là sur une des régions,
l'attente des des Français, à quel
moment est-ce qu'ils sont prêts
d'investir quelques milliers d'euros des
étraines qui vont donner à leurs enfants
pour faire en sorte que tu développes
des emplois dans leur territoire et
cetera. Elle est entre 5 et 6 %. Donc on
est capable de monter un système qui
répond à l'attente de retour sur
investissement des Français et des
ménages et qui en même temps finance cet
outil productif sans aucun problème. Il
n'y a pas si tu veux de blocage
financier sur les flux. On peut le
faire.
OK. Là, j'ai écouté notre chef
d'étatmajor. Vous avez entendu son
discours auprès de l'association des
maires de France qu'il fallait se
préparer à perdre nos enfants pour
défendre la France, qu'il fallait que
les maires trouvent des places pour nos
militaires parce que comme on a vendu
toutes nos casernes, on sait plus où
loger nos militaires. Est-ce que le
milieu de l'entreprise est prêt à
naviguer en temps de guerre ? Est-ce que
l'État se prépare à mettre notre
économie en temps de guerre ? Une
économie de guerre, c'est-à-dire Renault
va faire des drones peut-être
d'assau, bon, on va continuer de faire
des petits avions.
Est-ce que la métallurgie va pouvoir
suivre ? Est-ce qu'on va pouvoir se
réarmer sans énergie ? Est-ce que les
entreprises
ne sont pas en short face à la guerre
qui arrive ?
Je sais
attention, j'ai eu le le président du
MEDF il y a pas très longtemps ici, il
m'a dit "On est en short."
Alors, je saurais pas répondre à cette
question là et je pense qu'on a pas de
plan si tu veux pour basculer. Moi ce
que le point qui me marque sur les
dernières années, c'est qu'on s'est tapé
une série de crises économiques,
d'accord ? Les unes après les autres et
cetera. la résilience, c'est la
résistance la capacité de s'adapter de
notre tissu industriel, moi il m'a quand
même un peu bluffé. OK, on s'est pris un
certain nombre de coûts et cetera.
1000 milliards fait Macron.
Mais mais [grognement] là, tu parles de
la dette. Mais d'accord sur la partie,
mais tu en as eu d'autres des crises. Tu
as pas eu que celles qui ont été
couvertes par la dette. Moi, je trouve
que le tissu industriel certes, il s'est
raptissé, il grandit pas comme je
souhaiterais, mais il a été quand quand
même capable de s'adapter à pas mal de
crises euh notamment d'approvisionnement
et cetera. Donc, je ferai le pari en
tous les cas d'une d'une capacité
d'adaptation et d'une résilience qui est
peut-être supérieure à celle qu'on
imagine. Il y a pas de plan pour aller
dans l'univers que tu décris et je le
souhaite pas qu'on aille dans cet
univers là d'ailleurs, mais on a quand
même un tissu industriel qui a montré sa
capacité d'adaptation et de résistance.
Monsieur mon ministre, faisant euh si on
fait le un bref scanner de la situation
des secteurs, c'est intéressant de
regarder par secteur. Euh l'agriculture,
elle descend, elle est de moins en moins
capable de répondre à nos besoins
alimentaires. Bon, donc sur le plan de
la souveraineté et de l'indépendance et
de la capacité à produire, on est pas
bien.
sur tout ce qui concerne l'automobile,
on est attaqué très sérieusement et on
risque de perdre nos grandes
entreprises. C'est ça qui se prépare si
on ne bouge pas. Et c'est on prend pas
des mesures protectionnistes dignes de
ce nom au plan européen ou peut-être
faudra-t-il au plan national. Si on
regarde le numérique, on est colonisé
donc on est dans la main des Américains.
Si on regarde la finance, on n'est pas
loin de l'être également. hein.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, on n' pas
d'autonomie de de grandes décisions et
on n'est pas mobile. Euh sur la défense,
on est très bon parce qu'on a une
politique industrielle d'État. On a mis
20 milliards par an depuis euh 50 ans.
Donc évidemment, on est très bon, on est
très solide, mais c'est petit. Si on
regarde l'aéronautique, on est bon mais
c'est les Allemands quand même qui ont
pris une bonne partie d'Airbus. Quant au
luxe, bon, c'est bien la maroquinerie,
tout ça, mais ça ne suffit pas. Voilà.
Donc, quand on regarde euh la situation
[grognement] euh je pense qu'on est
vraiment pas prêt, ça c'est sûr, puisque
on n pas organisé notre capacité à être
indépendant. Donc, il y a des beaucoup
de ministères, ministère de l'économie
et de la souveraineté industrielle,
ministère de l'agriculture et la
souveraineté alimentaire, ministère de
et cetera. Mais euh c'est un mot mais
les politiques n'ont pas eu les effets
parce qu'il y en a pas eu en fait de
grandes politiques de reconstruction de
notre indépendant. [grognement] Donc en
fait le programme c'est le livre
d'Olivier sur l'industrie. Voilà. Alors
la ministre d'agriculture a lancé des
plans de souveraineté.
J'ai accepté d'écrire un bout parce
qu'elle me l'a demandé. Je le fais de
façon bénévole parce que je trouve que
c'est pour la France et moi je suis à la
disposition du gouvernement de la France
quel qu'il soit. Donc j'ai accepté
d'écrit. Je vois dans quel
Jordan Bardin
bah il est pas au gouvernement que je
sache pour l'instant
l'année prochaine il le sera.
Écoutez moi je considère que le gouverne
de la France c'est le gouvernement
légitime. Voilà c'est comme ça. Après
euh les électeurs ils font ce qu'ils ont
à faire hein et moi je ferai ce que je
veux dans l'isoloir. Donc moi, une chose
que je peux dire, c'est que il y a un
travail qui est fait avec les filières,
mais je vois tout ce qu'il faut
remonter, les écart des des difficultés
puis je vois bien aussi tout ce qu'on a
laissé s'installer comme réglementation
absurde qui détruisent l'économie. C'est
qu'en fait on n pas construit le
compromis intelligent entre écologie et
agriculture, économie agricole.
[grognement]
Pourtant, c'est le même préfixe. On
aurait dû on aurait dû trouver les voies
et les moyens de travailler ensemble. Ça
n'a pas été fait. Conséquence, on
[grognement] a on a absolument rendu
impossible la production sur notre sol
nationale d'un grand nombre de
productions. Donc moi, je suis chargé
toutes les filières de production
végétale spécialisée là. Alors l'huile
d'olive, le lin, le houblon, tout des
choses de la vie quotidienne he qu'on a
tous les jours dans notre vie. Et bien
euh on a des productions très fortes et
puis on a des filières qui sont on
importe à 95 %. Je repense à une note
qui avait été signée par le haut
commissaire au plan un certain François
Baou qui plus tard est devenu premier
ministre qui s'appelait la bataille du
commerce extérieur et il avait écrit, je
le cite de mémoire, je pense pas
beaucoup le déformé. J'avais dit par
certains aspects l'économie française a
les traits d'une économie en voie de
développement.
Tout était dit mais c'était déjà il y a
6 ou 7 ans. Le temps passe et il ne se
passe rien. Donc on a besoin là d'un
redressement d'urgence. [grognement]
Juste pour illustrer le propos he
d'Arnaud quelque chose.
Prends ton temps. Olivier he il y a pas
juste. Prends ton temps.
Ouais alors je prends mon temps pour
compléter ce que dit Arnaud. Il y a
quelque chose qui nous manque par
exemple quelles sont les productions
essentielles ? dire demain on est face à
des crises, on sait qu'elles vont venir
climatiques, militaire, géopolitique,
commercial et cetera. Quelles sont les
productions dont on a besoin de garder
la maîtrise sur notre territoire afin
d'être sûr que la colonne vertébrale de
notre économie, elle s'effondre pas ?
Question, elle est assez intuitive.
Après, je te mets devant une feuille
blanche et je te dis commence à faire la
liste, ça devient compliqué parce que
c'est pas évident. Le concept est
simple. la production essentielle dont
on a besoin pour maintenir notre outil
productif. Ça ça va, on visualise bien
dans le détail, c'est difficile à faire.
Cette liste-là n'existe pas en France.
Personne dans l'État n'y a réfléchi.
Sectoriellement, on a fait un peu les
médicaments critiques, un peu ceci, un
peu cela. La liste des métaux des métaux
stratégiques par la Commission
européenne fait rigoler, tu vois. Enfin
et puis les objectifs qui nous sont
donnés sont au doigt mouillés
complètement. même la cour, je crois que
la cour des comptes européennes où il y
a un rapport officiel qui s'étonne
d'objectifs qui sont absolument pas
justifiables, justifiés. Enfin, c'est
voilà. Donc, il faut qu'on ait une
réflexion sérieuse. On a lancé un projet
dans le conservatoire national des
arrêts métiers pour faire justement
cette liste là. Quelles sont les
méthodes qui fonctionnent et cetera ?
C'est des choses pas enfin difficiles
mais accessibles. On va le faire, on va
la sortir cette liste, elle sera pas
parfaite. Une fois que tu as ça, tu as
un outil sur lequel tu peux orienter ta
politique industrielle en disant bah
écoute, les cartes Panini digitalisées
qui ont fait l'objet de tweet du
président de la République et du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
parce qu'ils avaient levé des centaines
de millions d'euros, je suis pas sûr que
l'utilité sociale et pour la nation soit
la même que celle d'avoir une bonne
filière de végétaux qui te produisent
des protéines et qui te protègent contre
de l'importation de choses absolument
essentielles. On va commencer à pouvoir,
je dirais, [raclement de gorge]
s'orienter vers des vraies priorités qui
correspondent non pas au monde des
années 90 qu'on a rêvé avec du libre
échange, qui a créé de la richesse,
c'est indéniable. Dans un monde de paix
et de bisounours sans doute, c'est plus
notre monde. Aujourd'hui, tuas un monde
de rapport de force. Il faut qu'on
adapte notre outil productif. C'est
possible.
Est-ce que je peux compléter le
complément ?
Je vous en prie, monsieur mon ministre.
Alors, je prends l'exemple des
médicaments.
Mais je gratte 10 minutes de plus.
Vas-y, continue.
Il y a Je prends l'exemple des
médicaments qui a été évoqué par Olivier
et Jy. Euh les médicaments, on a euh un
rapport de 2016 qui disait "On a 2000
médicaments sensibles sur lesquels on
est dépendant de l'étranger et on est en
rupture de stock, soit potentielle, soit
acquise, soit montré, démontré et acté."
Bon,
déjà, il y en a qui ont fait leur
boulot.
Euh le gouvernement a pris à organiser
en pendant toutes ces années et
notamment après le Covid, c'est pas
seulement le Dolibran, hein, il y avait
quand même d'autres choses à peu près
une entre 20 et 30, j'ai plus le chiffre
exact malheureusement.
Liprin qui a été vendu aux États-Unis
là, c'est ça ?
Non non non, mais c'est je parle, c'est
une marque de l'prindre, c'était
paracétamol, les principes actifs du
paracétamol. Donc parmi [grognement]
les projets de relocalisation en France
sur le sol français, il y avait des
projets pour en d'une vingtaine de euh
principes actifs ou molécules très
importantes pour notre indépendance euh
euh sanitaire.
Euh je crois savoir que il y en a pas
beaucoup qui ont été réalisés, hein.
D'ailleurs, le projet sur le
paracétamone n'est toujours pas fait.
Donc on a un vrai sujet entre le
discours et les actes. Et donc les
médicaments critiques, il y en a un
paquet.
Je rappelle quand même que les
médicaments alcaloïdes, c'est-à-dire
ceux qui servent à endormir le patient
avant toute opération chirurgicale,
c'est fondamental, je crois. Et bien, on
en importe pour 10 milliards par an.
10 milliards par an. Donc on n' pas eu
l'idée de monter 10 usines à 1 milliard
de chiffres d'affaires sur le sol
français alors qu'on a toutes les major
du médicament soit français, soit
européen, soit mondial en France
[grognement] pour produire ces
médicaments. Ça ferait presque 1/3 allez
1/e un 5 pardon 1/5e de la balance
commerciale résolu sur un produit enfin
une famille de produits.
C'est c'est intéressant. Je vous je vous
Non, je prends faut faut être concret
dans vos émissions. Alors, je me permets
d'apporter des éléments.
On peut dire pareil sur les
antibiotiques.
Bah,
vas-y.
Bah 80 % de nos antibiotiques sont
importés d'Inde aujourd'hui. Donc tu
aurais une crise, on a eu la crise du
Covid, c'était viral, il fallait des
vaccins. Demain, tu as une crise
sanitaire qui est bactériologique
ou une crise diplomatique. Et l'un nous
dit "Maintenant, tu vas faire moins ton
malin avec moi parce que sinon
et ça c'est la question de la dépendance
et de la souveraineté." et ben après tu
te mets à genou et si l'â te dit bah je
veux les plants de terrafal, tu lui
fileras tes plants de terrafal parce que
tu auras besoin d'antibiotiques pour
sauver ta population. Voilà ce type de
conséquence, c'est là où tu perds
complètement ta souveraineté. Alors et
je et je rebondis aussi sur ce que
disait Arnaud, une des grandes
difficultés depuis quelques années,
c'est ce que j'appelle la face fashion
des politiques industrielles. On est
parti avec les start-up. Alors, j'ai pas
de dire les start-up, le trou et cetera.
OK. Après, on a eu le Covid, donc on
nous a fait une politique de
relocalisation des médicaments. Puis
après, on nous a fait une politique euh
loi industrie verte sur OK. Après, on a
eu euh naturellement les premiers euh la
la guerre en Ukraine. Donc, on nous fait
un un une politique sur euh euh sauf
toi. Euh
oui, bah il faut il faut rendre à César
ce qui est à César, hein.
Euh on nous fait une une politique sur
la défense et puis maintenant euh oura
euh il y a 100 milliards d'euros
d'investissements essentiellement
américains qui viennent sur les data
centers. Donc, il faudrait qu'on fasse
en 5 ou 6 ans, tu as eu cinq priorités
de politique industrielle en France.
Mais mais ça peut pas marcher un cycle
industriel.
Mais on sait tous que Macron n'a pas de
mol épinière, ça tout le monde le sait.
Fait ce naim le nucléaire, il a pas de
molpinière, il a pas de cap, il sait pas
de dire quelque chose. Bon, on va pas
rentrer dans les tails. Vous êtes en
train de m'énerver tous les deux. Donc
on en est bien navré. On était
[grognement] les bout les goûts de cop
il paraît. Tu sais,
on en est bien navré optimiste et on
veut pas on te démontre qu'il y a des
solutions. Non mais je veux bien je veux
bien des solutions mais je pense que le
constat n'est pas bon. Quand j'entends
Arnaud dire, il a tout à fait raison, on
on claque 10 milliards pour faire pour
faire rentrer les alcaloïdes chez nous,
on pourrait faire 10 usines à un
milliard, on pourrait faire bosser des
gens, ainsi de suite, ainsi de suite.
Moi, je vais je vais poser la question
très directement. Est-ce que vous avez
pas l'impression qu'on est en train de
mettre notre [__] de pays en laisse à
dessin pour que la France secoule dans
une Europe fédérale proxy des États-Unis
? Est-ce que vous avez pas l'impression
que ça fait des années qu'on a une élite
européenne qui est bibonnée avec du fric
américain ? Des réseaux qui sont
bibronnés avec du fric américain pour
faire terre les voies comme Arnaud
Montbourg ou autres sur la
réindustrialisation
la souveraineté française ? Est-ce que
vous avez pas l'impression que de
l'intérieur, excusez-moi l'expression,
monsieur mon ministre, on nous castre de
l'intérieur pour éviter que la France
prenne le lead de l'Europe ? et on
castre avec l'aide des Allemands proxy
américain.
Donc la question elle est très direct.
Est-ce que vous avez pas J'entends votre
constat de on peut faire si on a plein
d'argent, c'est super cool. Est-ce que
vous avez
C'est déjà pas mal des solutions ? Non
mais c'est très bien. Après, il faut
faire le bon constat.
Donc c'est pas du fatalisme.
Je vois que la France est mis en laisse
avec un collier étrangleur que nos
élites ne défendent pas notre nation
soit par incompétence, soit par
forfaiture, soit pour des questions. On
va pas rentrer dans le détail pour pas
se prendre un procès ce soir.
[souffle coupé] J'ai vraiment
l'impression que notre pays est mis au
pas.
Est-ce que vous avez le même constat que
moi,
monsieur mon ministre ? Alors,
Alstom, Arabel, on voit les Américains
faire du Arabel.
Alors,
on peut la liste est longue technique.
Bah moi, j'ai fait la liste des patrons
de boîte hein, euh qui ont reçu un
chèque pour se vendre
presque à presque aux enchères à
l'enfant.
C'était en eurou en dollar. Ah bah je
pense qu'il y avait un peu des deux
hein. C'était un peu ça. On fait pas de
part ce soir. Ah non mais je vais donner
les chiffres, j'ai donné les nom
peut-être, c'est encore mieux. Je l'ai
déjà dit devant une commission d'enquête
parlementaire.
Euh donc je je peux le redire
ici avec toute la même sincérité et
liberté. 1 Alstom euh
c'était un chèque d'une vingtaine de
millions pour euh Cron et une garantie
d'immunité des poursuites pour
corruption mondiale de la part du
département of justice euh de
l'administration américaine.
Pilinco, Thierry Pilinco, patron de
Techniip a fait une fausse fusion
entrega avec FMC, une boîte Texane qui
était en vérité en grave difficulté mais
dont un rapport de Goldman Sax avait
montré toutes les vertus et qu'il a gobé
comme ça. Et d'ailleurs dans le conseil
d'administration, il y a des gens qui
ont refusé de voter, ils ont jamais
voulu parler malheureusement mais la BPI
et l'Institut français du pétrole,
c'estàd celui qui détient les brevets du
général des Gaul sur l'œil and gaz on
voté pour
quand même le dire.
Ça ça a été dit dans une commission.
Décisions qui ont été prises.
Ça ça a été dit ça a été vocalisé et
verbalisé dans une commission.
Bah je l'ai dit à la commission
d'enquête parlementaire.
Vous avez eu des procès pour ça ou pas ?
Moi, on me fait aucun procès. Je le
regrette parce que j'apporterai les
preuves et les témoins parce que je ne
dis que ce que je je vérifier quand
même. Bon, on raconte pas n'importe
quoi. C'est la France là, c'est un enjeu
très important. C'est notre bien commun
en quelque sorte, hein. Alors, après, je
continue. Euh, il y a eu la farge. La
farge, ça a été la fusion avec Olgim. Ne
vous inquiétez pas, euh tout reste en
France. Bah non, tout est parti. Et en
plus, on a eu des histoires et le
président
de l'époque qui a touché un gros chèque
lui aussi parce qu'ils ont tous eu pour
moi le prix de la trahison de la France,
je l'ai déjà exprimé, c'est entre c'est
15 millions en moyenne. Donc
mais vous êtes sûr parce que je peux pas
vous
les précautions ou pas de précaution.
Ils ont pas trahi la France ces gens-là.
Bah, ils ont vendu un un groupe du CAC
40 dans des conditions qui ont fait
perdre le contrôle à la nation de ce
groupe [grognement] contre un chèque,
une rémunération euh extraordinaire euh
extrêmement importante euh qui euh
montre à quel point finalement la
vénalité dirige dirige les affaires,
hein. Ça, on n'est pas surpris. Enfin,
quand on a une responsabilité de
gouvernance et euh qu'on est à la tête
d'un petit morceau de France, Alstom,
c'est un morceau de France, la PAR,
c'est un morceau de France, Technipp,
c'est un morceau de France euh je suis
désolé et Alcatel, les restes de la CGE,
la compagnie général électrique, il y
avait Alst, Thomson, Alcatel. Thomson
disparu, Alstom vendu en morceaux,
Alcatel Michel Combe
15 millions environ 13 millions je crois
pour vendre à Nokia alors que on aurait
pu racheter nous Nokia,
excusez-moi, on était à peu près au même
niveau. Donc si vous voulez tous ces
gens qui vendent et qui prennent un gros
chèque, moi pour moi, ça fait partie du
tableau de l'abandon de la France par
les élites. On parle souvent des
gouvernants mais c'est des patrons de
grande boîte. C'est pas des c'est des
gens qui ont fait de grandes études qui
doivent tout. Ils ont défilé la plupart
sur les Champsélysées en uniforme parce
qu'ils avaient fait l'école
polytechnique. Moi, pour moi, c'est très
grave ce qui s'est passé et ça continue
hein. Euh, ça continue. Bah après, vous
avez eu [grognement] Etilor et Lux
Shotica qui est moins grave, mais on
pourrait continuer comme ça.
Alors, j'ai monsieur le ministre, vous
connaissez mon point de vue sur qui doit
protéger la France pour des questions de
renseignement économique, pour des
questions de d'atteinte au au aux
intérêts français.
Je vais vous répéter ma ma marotte. Que
font les services de renseignement ? Ah
ben non, mais moi mon bon les services
de renseignement, ils sont pas ils sont
pas à l'époque quand j'étais au
gouvernement, ils étaient pas au niveau
et même moi je me souviens avoir rappelé
euh quand nous avons découvert le
complot contre Alstom euh avec la
complicité de Cron euh pour nous vendre
euh à général électrique aux Américains.
J'ai appelé le patron de la DGSE,
monsieur Bajolet, qui a fait des
mémoires fortes honorables.
Je lui ai dit, "Nous sommes nous sommes
euh selon le témoignage de la famille de
Pierucci que j'avais fait recueillir par
mes collaborateurs à l'époque puisque je
m'étais porté au secours de Pierouci. il
vous raconter cette triste histoire et
lui a souffert énormément pour avoir
résisté et refusé de collaborer avec le
système d'espionnage que le département
de justice américain décidait au plus
haut niveau voulait mettre en place
contre nos intérêts français et contre
une entreprise française qui s'appelait
ATOM. Il a refusé, il l'a payé 2 années
de prison en orange avec des chaînes au
pieds et toute la violence à l'intérieur
des prisons. Voilà ce qui s'est passé.
Euh donc euh quand j'apprends ça, je
j'appelle le service des le patron des
services secrets un certain Bajolet euh
Berdard de son petit nom.
Euh je lui dis "Nous sommes pour nous
nous sommes euh nous sommes euh euh
espionnés euh il y a il y a quand même
une opération qui est en train de se
monter. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
? Ah nous nous n'écoutons pas les
Américains. Je dis pardon. Il y a eu
Snowen qui a révélé que nous avions eu
75 millions de conversations qui avaient
été euh écoutées par l'agence NSA. Et
d'ailleurs, quand Pierucci s'est pointé
pour dire "Je ne veux pas reconnaître
les faits, on lui a sorti 1 million de
mail. Son cas lui a dit il me faut 3 ans
pour les lire et ça vous coûtera un
million de dollars ou quelque chose
comme ça." Bon qu'est-ce que ça voulait
dire ? Ça veut dire qu'ils utilisent la
NSA pour pomper l'information
de façon illégale, puis ensuite il la
recycle, il la donne au au système
judiciaire qui en fait des procès pour
nous piquer nos entreprises et on
appelle ça des alliés.
Et alors évidemment le voyage au
Washington avec entre François Hollande
et Barack Obama, pas un mot sur
l'histoire des 75
millions de conversations écoutées en
Europe sur les dirigeants dont nous
donc moi je vous peux vous parler de
service de renseignement. C'est de
renseignement, ils font ce que les
dirigeants politiques leur demandent de
faire puisquils sont sous contrôle
politique. Heureusement d'ailleurs,
heureusement, c'est la démocratie hein,
je vous rappelle, il y a pas de de il a
pas d'autonomie des services.
Olivier, en terme de guerre économique,
on fait quoi là ? En terme de guerre
économique, est-ce qu'il faut être plus
invasif ? Est-ce qu'il faut être plus
corrosif ? Est-ce qu'il faut arrêter ?
J'allais être vulgaire. Donc, on va
employer un terme médical. Est-ce qu'il
faut arrêter de se prendre des fistules
anales par les États-Unis ?
Non, je commande pas. C'est hors propos
comme image.
C'est un ter c'est un terme médical.
Euh il y a il y a il y a plein de choses
sur lesquelles on n'est pas formé en
France sur l'intelligence économique.
Vous parlez d'énormes dossiers.
Non, je parle pas d'intelligence
économique, là je parle de renseignement
économique. C'est le côté au-dessus de
de l'intelligence économique parce que
l'intelligence économique en général,
c'est l'économie de l'intelligence.
pas Ouais, faut je je vois pas le où tu
veux m'emmener avec cette inversion des
termes.
C'est des branques.
Mais déjà qu'on commence à à accepter
que on est dans un monde qui n'est pas
un monde de bisonnance, je vais te
raconter une histoire qui qui s'est
passée, que j'ai vécu. Je suis dans un
pays de l'est de l'Europe. Je construis
une usine pour Saint-Gobin, un grand
groupe. Et juste en face de l'autre côté
du Danube, je suis en Roumanie, en
Bulgarie, il y a un concurrent turc qui
s'installe et je découvre au bout de
quelques mois que mon comptable roumain
file l'info sur les prix que je
j'utilise sur mes clients. D'accord ?
pour des sommes dérisoires. Tu n'es pas
préparé quand tu es quand tu es formé en
France à des choses aussi simples que
ça. Donc la première chose, vous parlez
de grands dossiers mais commençons à
mettre dans nos écoles d'inget dans nos
écoles de commerce la base de cette je
dirais avertissement, j'ai pas envie de
dire paranoïa, ça te ferait trop plaisir
mais c'est non mais moi on me fait pas
plaisir moi.
Mais mais ça si tu veux on le vit tous
les jours.
Tu es un perdre de l'année. DGSE mais
des hommes de paille à la tête de nos
entreprises à l'étranger pour éviter les
phénomènes de rançon, de mafia et de
pression. Est-ce que la DGSE que c'est
une culture de pays qu'on a qui commence
à la base et sur lesquelles on doit
rentrer en se disant encore une fois il
y a une concurrence, elle n'est pas
loyale, elle utilise des des déloyautés
sur des coups mais aussi tu dois le
faire. Ouais ben qu'on commence par là
après tu traiteras le sujet par en haut.
Mais moi ce je voilà tous les cas
Olivier n'est pas un perdre ni de
l'année ni du siècle et simplement sa
vision de la construction
d'une entreprise et de la façon de la
faire tourner bah on voit bien que ça
fuit de partout donc ça a quand même du
travail
jour un jour on a reçu un très très
grand général ici qui m'a dit voilà il
faut être parano pour protéger la France
lui dit non mon général faut être alerte
j'aime bien le terme ouais
mais est-ce qu'on t'apprend à être
alerte quand on t'apprend uniquement à
respecter les modes d'emploi by the book
et on a quand même beaucoup de ça. C'est
ce qui se passe dans notre
administration ministre alerte et
vigilant. Ça existe encore en France des
gens alertes et vigilants ? Est-ce que
ça existe des vrais patriotes ? Je parle
pas des nationalistes de plateau télé.
Est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui ont
réellement saisi que la France va
s'effondrer, qu'on va être déclassé pour
les 100 prochaines années, qu'on va
subir ce déclassement et que nos plus
faibles, nos enfants, notre système
scolaire, notre système de santé, nos
vieux,
nos nos universités,
on va pas pouvoir rattraper. Les
intérêts de la dette française à l'année
représentent deux fois notre
consommation d'hydrocarbure.
Est-ce qu'il y a encore des Français en
France ?
Alors, je vais répondre sur cette
objurgation
en disant que
on va aller à Bibrac tous les deux hein.
Attention,
il y a beaucoup de Français qui prennent
conscience de la gravité de la
situation.
Ils en sont conscients parce qu'ils le
vivent dans leur vie quotidienne. Ils
voient les conséquences s'accumuler sur
leur vie et il voit bien que il va
falloir que on fasse preuve d'un courage
collectif
colossal
important pas démesuré parce que c'est
il y a en France une et je ne je le
crois sincèrement il y a énormément
d'abord il y a une grande éducation et
conscience aux enjeux collectifs. croit
qu'on en pense et il va falloir qu'on
remonte cette pente ensemble et parce
qu'on va le faire ensemble comme quand
on a reconstruit le pays après la
deuxème guerre mondiale, c'est nous
grands-parents, moi c'est mes
grands-parents il ont participé à ça, ça
pas été facile hein. Il y avait des
tickets d'alimentation en France, il y
avait il y avait des villes effondrées
par quoi on allait recommencer. Bon donc
on en a vu d'autres, faut pas non plus
dramatiser. On est capable de le faire.
La preuve c'est qu'il y a des gens qui
le pensent. Il y a des gens qui savent
le faire. Et il y a plein de gens qui
sont volontaires pour agir. Donc
normalement ça ça fait un peuple qui se
relève. OK.
Et tu as besoin d'une génération. Tu as
besoin
je fais encore le mauvais flic. Le
niveau de mat sont très très puissants.
C'est difficile de les interdire.
Notre niveau en math
chute, le niveau scolaire chute, la
prochaine génération censé relever.
Et c'est des illforme
du bac. C'est une mauvaise réforme. Elle
a été complètement ratée. Les résultats
sont catastrophiques. Bon et ben, on
n'est pas capable de se réformer. Il va
bien falloir le faire.
On le fait dans un sens, on peut le
faire dans l'autre.
Encore une fois. Enfin, je quel est le
c'est une réforme, c'est un texte, ça se
change. He la loi, c'est une décision
des hommes et des femmes à un moment
donné et tu les mets de et tu les
changes. Bien entendu qu'il faut le
changer. Moi je le vois tous les jours,
j'enseigneam on voit les personnes qui
arrivent. Il y a un vrai sujet de niveau
en sciences et technique. Enfin, je il y
a il y a aucun doute. On intercale même
de temps en temps, on fait faire une
année de licence en plus afin de faire
une remise à niveau avant de prendre des
gens en niveau ingénieur. C'est-à-dire
que on a cette souplesse là, donc on
fait un ingénieur en bac + 6 et pas en
bac + 5 pour refaire une mise à niveau.
Ça c'est la réalité de tous les jours.
Elle est dans les statistiques, elle est
de partout. Encore une fois, ça se
change. Ça se change avec de la volonté
et un peu de courage. Encore une fois,
qu'est-ce C'est pas un problème de
budget là-dessus. C'est pas un problème
de majorité politique, c'est un problème
de volonté, de projet et de courage. Ça
ça coûte rien. Et
mais s'il y avait du courage en
politique, ça serait, n'est-ce pas,
monsieur mon ministre ?
Oh, ça se trouve.
Ça se trouve où ? Ça se trouve où ?
Ça se trouve, il y en a, il y en a, il y
en a. Non, mais faut pas désespérer bill
en cours, hein. D'accord. Il y a du
courage
dans toute et plus la situation va
devenir critique et difficile, plus les
hommes, les femmes qui ont ce courage
vont se lever. vous allez voir
apparaître et et nous ben nous on est
moi je suis un vieux maintenant hein
donc ben on aidera tous ces gens-là on
fera le nécessaire parmi les évolutions
qui ont eu lieu là récemment le mot
protectionnisme c'était un gros mot il y
a encore 2 ans. Tu pouvais pas le sortir
sans compte taxe de coloration politique
et c ben c'est en général la vraiment le
11 c'est-à-dire dans le tissu ambiant en
face de toi. Non non, moi j'ai pas cette
analyse là. Tous les gens qui se
faisaient taxer de attention méchants
nationalistaux patriés et tout, c'était
à chaque fois le même groupe,
je dirais le même groupe antique. Le mot
le mot protectionniste était considéré
comme un gros mot, je pense assez
collectivement en France. Moi, je sais
que
comme patriotisme
éventuellement on peut le mettre dans le
même dans la même catégorie. Et ça en
l'espace de quelques années, ça a
évolué. Quand ici hier, mais dans la
plupart de mes conférences, j'explique
un truc simple. On a un projet de
société en Europe, on a des ambitions
environnementales, on a un modèle
social. C'est pas le même entre la
Pologne et la France, mais on a cette
volonté euh d'avoir un modèle social de
protection du faible et cetera. Ça
coûte. OK. Si tu mets des entreprises
qui payent ça en face d'entreprise qui
n'ont pas à payer la prot nos ambitions
environnementales ou notre modèle
social, c'est une concurrence des loyal.
Tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux sur la
compétitivité européenne, il y a des
choses à faire de simplification et
cetera. Tu as un plancher qui est notre
projet de société. Tu peux pas descendre
en dessous. Donc à un moment donné, il
faudra bien expliquer que il faut se
protéger contre des productions qui
n'ont pas la même structure de coût, qui
payent pas nos ambitions
environnementales, qui payent pas notre
modèle social. Maintenant ça passe comme
dans du beurre quand tu dis ça c'est une
évidence pour la plupart
c'est toujours pas encore fait
c'est pas fait mais au niveau de la
population
et ça tarde à venir
et ça tarde à venir mais tu as une prise
de conscience qui a été faite. Donc ce
type de changement dont tu parles, ils
se ils sont en train de se dérouler et
moi en tous les cas comme tu disais on
est dans une démocratie faut avoir
confiance au système. Si tu as une
population qui pense de cette façonlà
qu'on peut s'en sortir, qui sait qu'il y
aura des efforts à faire pour recréer de
la valeur, ça va se faire.
Tibi, c'est c'était quoi Tibi déjà ?
Philippe Tibi,
c'est pas l'ancien patron du BS ?
Je sais pas, peut-être, je ne sais pas,
je ne saurais pas le dire. Je
[grognement] ne sais pas.
Je demande à la communauté de me
retrouver l'information. Euh, je vais
bientôt prendre les questions de la
communauté, les enfants sur Twitter.
Donc faites-moi plaisir, faites-moi
monter les questions qui vous
intéressent le plus avec un petit pouce,
ça nous permettra de gagner du temps.
Pendant temps, n'oubliez pas de nous
soutenir aussi, c'est important parce
que nous nous sommes totalement
indépendants. On on grâce à notre
communauté, on prend aucune subvention,
on paye la TV en dedans, on paye tout
plein pot, on fait pas d'optimisation
fiscale et on essaie de tenir malgré le
DSA. C'est quoi le DSA, monsieur mon
ministre ? Digital Service Act. Ah oui,
c'est ça.
Eh, encore un truc de l'Europe.
Non non, mais moi je suis très mauvais
en acronyme, je ne connais que SNCF,
savoir nager comme Fernandis.
Ouais. Et RATP, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ah, ça vous le savez mieux que moi.
Rentre avec tes pieds. Non. [rires]
Et euh donc la communauté, s'il vous
plaît, financez-nous sur Tipi, on a
besoin de vous. C'est très important.
Toi, tu peux appuyer sur tout bouquin,
sur ton petit bouton. Euh Philippe Tibi,
président du BS en France et président
de la mafie. Merci.
Avant qu'on prenne les questions de la
communauté, on va revenir sur les
questions de prédation et les questions
de renseignement économique.
Qui est-ce qui aide les chefs
d'entreprise ? Qui est-ce qui va voir
les chefs d'entreprise ou qui va former
dans les universités pour prévenir, pour
essayer de sensibiliser
nos élites
à ça ? Quand on va bourlinguer à gauche
à droite qu'on discute avec des grands
patrons, on les a un peu sensibilisé. La
DGSE a fait un peu son boulot. Mais les
petites PME quand il voi des petites
chinoises
créché à côté de nos bases de
sous-marins, quand on voit des
Américains qui financent comme il va
bien. Vous dans votre toi Olivier dans
ton école, est-ce que tu as une UV du
genre renseignement économique ? Je
parle pas intelligence économique.
Alors, je pourrais pas te répondre si au
conservateur national des métiers il y
en a. Il y a quelques directement parce
que j'en suis pas responsable. Il y a
pas mal de choses qui se font sur les le
renseignement, l'information que tu peux
avoir notamment en ouvert via sur
internet mais en allant un peu
profondément avec un centre notamment à
en Bretagne qui est qui est très
chouette là-dessus. Donc je par contre
moi dans ma vie professionnelle si tu
veux, j'ai appris ça sur le tas. Mais
c'est une blague.
Mais mais je te je t'assure quand quand
tu es j'ai été envoyé en Roumanie, la
Roumanie n'est pas un pays ça va
beaucoup mieux maintenant. C'était avant
de rentrer dans l'Union européenne mais
on va dire l'éthique du business n'était
pas parfaite pour employer des des mots
gentils. J'ai été confronté à des
tentatives de corruption directe parce
que je représentais un intérêt
économique. J'ai appris sur le tas face.
Comment tu réponds non ? Comment tu
esquives ? Comment tu
tu as débriefé quand tu es rentré. Ah
bah bien sûr.
Tuas tu as été débriefé auprès de tes
voisins ou tu as appelé la DGSE en
disant écoute on a essayé.
Ah non quand je dis débriefer c'est
c'est des choses en interne où on
partage entre dirigeants si tu veux.
Mais
il faut que les dirigeants aident aussi
les services de renseignement aussi
légal hein.
Et OK peut-être mais ce que je te tu me
dis qui est venu vers moi et je te
réponds on a je pense que la plupart des
chefs d'entreprise apprennent ça sur le
tas quand ils y sont confrontés. Al
moi je voudrais faire pas une expérience
personnelle. J'ai créé une entreprise
d'équipe mentiers de la filière
nucléaire.
C'est une entreprise qui dont je suis
l'un des cfondateurs, je suis j'en suis
le président euh et j'ai reçu la visite
des services de sécurité.
Mais parce que c'est monsieur le
ministre.
Non, parce que tout le monde a reçu et
il y a eu et on nous a averti sur la
filière nucléaire. Pourquoi ? Ben parce
que on fabrique des pièces critiques.
C'est une petite PME, hein. On fait 40
millions de chiffres d'affaires, c'est
pas une grosse boîte. On a 230 employés.
Euh c'est c'est ce sont des des petites
PME que nous avons agrégé parce qu'on on
veut euh renforcer la filière nucléaire.
Donc ça c'est mon travail de c'est ma
vie d'aujourd'hui hein dans
l'agriculture, l'industrie. On construit
des entreprises de souveraineté et on a
reçu la visite des services et c'est pas
monsieur Montbourg parce qu'ils étaient
dans des réunions de la filière et
j'étais un parmi des milliers. Voilà. Et
donc il faisait la tour des Donc je veux
saluer les services de police qui font
ce travail de sensibilisation dans les
filières critiques.
Ils sont venus avec quoi ? Une petite
brochette, un pot de confiture. Comment
ça s'est passé ?
Non, ils sont nous ont abordé, ils nous
ont dit "Signalez-nous quand il y a tel
type de profil, attention à ceci." Et
d'ailleurs après moi je les ai consulté
sur un certain nombre de de contacts qui
avaient été pris avec moi et ils m'ont
immédiatement pris en charge la question
de l'information que je leur posais et
m'ont donné instruction et j'ai exécuté
les instructions.
C'est bien
ça fonctionne.
Si ça fonctionne.
Ne soyons pas pessimistes.
Mais c'est pas une histoire d'être
pessimiste. Je vois- 156 milliards en
balance commerciale.
Je vois Alstom se faire ouvrir. Je vois
d'autres boîtes se faire ouvrir. Je vois
Emmanuel Macron faire la tournée des
popotes. Tout le monde se fout de sa
gueule. Euh ça commence sérieusement à
me fatiguer là.
Gardons espoir. Il y a des solutions.
Une question de côté. le passe
numérique, l'identification
pour aller sur internet avec vos
coordonnées, nom prénom, les failles de
sécurité où nos boîtes se font ouvrir en
long large en travers même par des
gamins de 15 ans en Corse
euh quand on voit la NTS se faire ouvrir
avec nos passeports, nos cartes
d'identité, quand on voit France
travaille emploi, je sais plus comment
ils ont rebrandé ça. Bon, la NPE se
faire ouvrir quand on voit d'autres
organismes se faire ouvrir, alors là,
c'est que des données personnelles sur
les Français. Ça va être très très bien.
Quand on va rentrer en guerre, les
Russes, ils vont pouvoir appeler tous
nos téléphones portables, se faire
passer par la voisine, votre mère, votre
grand-mère en vous nous annonçant qu'il
y a eu un bombardement sur une centrale
de nucléaire pour propager la peur parce
que la peur, c'est plus qu'une bombe
nucléaire.
Votre avis, monsieur mon ministre sur la
robustesse de nos services informatiques
et surtout sur maintenant la nouvelle
lubi du reçu la vendeur lien,
c'est-à-dire s'authentifier
pour pouvoir aller sur internet. Si on
tombe sur un gouvernement qui n'a pas
les mêmes valeurs démocratiques ou de
d'ouverture d'esprit que nous cultivons,
c'est pas donner des lames de rasoir un
singe qui pourrait être détourné par des
criminels contre notre propre population
et surtout contre nos industries, nos
entreprises.
Ah moi je suis frappé par le fait et là
l'alerte est juste que nous sommes quand
même dans la main de systèmes qui sont
contrôlés ailleurs. Ça c'est la première
des choses et que toute la réaction
réglementaire de l'Union européenne sont
des côes sur les jambes de bois. Donc la
reprise en main de tout ça, ça veut dire
reprendre le cloud, être capable de
reprendre nos données, de les entreposer
chez nous et de construire une autonomie
européenne sérieuse qui n'a pas été
fait. Et j'en veux beaucoup à tous les
dirigeants européens qui ont laissé
s'installer euh le monopole des
hyperscalers américains qui domine
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des compartiments
de nos vies. Et la réaction
réglementaire américaine qui a provoqué
les moqueries injustifiées du
vice-président Vent à Munich euh montre
à quel point nous ne sommes pas capables
de reprendre le pouvoir qui est
économique et non pas réglementaire. Et
c'est bien là le sujet. Donc on impose
une réglementation qui est certainement
fort pertinente dans la plupart des cas,
mais qui pour moi ne règle aucun des
problèmes de souveraineté dans lesquels
nous sommes euh aujourd'hui en Lisée. Je
là-dessus, je pense que ça va durer
enfin vu l'état dans lequel on est,
hein, colonie numérique, il va falloir
remonter la pente étape par étape. Il y
a il y a des choses simples qu'on peut
faire. Les data centers viennent se
mettre en France parce qu'on a une prise
électrique décarbonée stable qu'on met
derrière l'électricité nucléaire. Donc
tu as une annonce entre 60, c'est des
chiffres, il y a ça monte jusqu'à 120,
ça dépend des sources. Milliards d'euros
d'investissement de data center. Très
bien. Vous venez en France, on a besoin
de stockage des données. OK. Quelle est
la contrepartie qu'on demande en terme
de valeur ajoutée ou de composants
français ou européens dedans ? Au début,
on n pas d'offre, ce sera un PUEM. Dans
10 ans, ce serait pas mal qu'on dise à
ces gens qui viennent s'installer chez
nous pour prendre notre électricité,
pour gérer nos données, de dire "Et ben
dans 10 ans, ce sera du 80 90 % de
composants électroniques et cetera qui
soient made in Europe." C'est un plan à
10 ans pour un bout de souveraineté,
hein, c'est pas sur les services, mais
juste sur le hard, sur le stockage de la
donnée pour qu'on puisse reprendre la
main. Voilà des choses assez simples à
faire. Elles sont faites de manière
timorée aujourd'hui. Il faudrait y
mettre un grand coup de booster. Tu as
quelques grands compartiments. On va
investir plus de 100 milliards d'euros
en France. Les data center, les réseaux
électriques, les centrales nucléaires,
la défense. Là-dessus, faut que tu
ailles à fond sur du made in France,
made in Europe et que tu mettes des
conditions. Et c'est une toute petite
marche hein, j'ai bien mais au moins tu
as fait la première marche, tu sais
faire un data center, tu as les
équipements pour et cetera et cetera et
cetera. l'identification sur les réseaux
pour aller surfer sur internet.
Moi, j'ai
pour protéger pour protéger les enfants.
Moi, j'ai j'ai une opinion personnelle,
mais après tu nous demandes de nous
exprimer avec une avec une expérience
sur le sujet. J'ai pas d'analyse
globale, moi. Je suis
C'est quoi ton opinion personnelle ?
Mon opinion personnelle, elle a été très
très bien euh exprimée par un jeune dans
une interview, enfin dans une dans un
questionnement au président de la
République qui était de tout simplement
dire pourquoi je vais donner ma carte
d'identité si c'est pour récupérer
toutes mes données personnelles ? Enfin,
je comprends pas la logique. Voilà, tout
simplement. ministre
même avis
question internet on va commencer par la
plus soft que je découvre avec vous
bonsoir monsieur Luanziboir monsieur
Montebourg salut la communauté comment
se protéger en tant que trentenair
patriote et motivés dans une France en
plein naufrage quels sont leurs conseils
au-delà du constat
je suis pas sûr d'avoir
euh se protéger de quelle manière
économiquement Euh euh moi je pense que
il faut s'engager.
Faut s'engager, c'est participer à
l'œuvre de reconstruction selon la façon
dont ce monsieur, cette personne euh qui
a une préoccupation euh
patriotique que je je j'approuve euh
qu'il s'engage dans la reconstruction du
pays et qu'il y travaille plutôt que
désespérer seul chercher les voies et
les moyens d'agir. Ce qui ce qui moi me
marque aujourd'hui, je l'ai dit en
introduction hein, c'est que on a un
système politique qui arrive plus à
porter de projets. Donc dans les années
à venir, je sais pas s'il y aura un ou
une personne qui est qui relèvera le
gant comme tu comme tu le souhaitais,
mais je pense qu'une bonne partie de
notre destin, elle est dans la société
civile, c'est-à-dire des associations
locales, des engagements locaux et
cetera. Ça fait un peu rire parce que ça
paraît des US et cetera, mais je pense
que c'est là où tu as l'énergie. Donc le
premier, je rejoins ce que dit Arnaud
hein, l'engagement. Engagez-vous pour
votre territoire. Il y a plein de façons
de le faire, pas seulement en faisant de
la politique, euh en créant de la
richesse, en devenant entrepreneur,
Arnaud l'a fait pour créer de la valeur
ajoutée, euh en vous engageant.
L'engagement territorial en société
civile, je pense qu'on a que ça. Euh
Olivier, tu prêches un converti, mon
ami. Euh nous, on a créé une chaîne
YouTube il y a 14 ans parce que on avait
à peu près 15 ans d'avance sur tout ce
qui se passait. On a été voir deux trois
potes dont le fondateur du programme
spatial français. On a exposé notre
notre vision. Il m'a dit "Engagez-vous,
faites-le, êtes les soyez les leaders,
secouez les médias." Marc Hulman nous a
dit "Fais-le, les journalistes font plus
leur boulot. Les politiciens font plus
Ça fait 15 ans qu'on fait ça avec un
travail préparatoire d'au moins 5 ans
avant."
Mais nous, on est dégoûté.
On est dégoûté. On voit les les partis
politiques vrier, ne pas connaître les
dossiers. On a plus de renseignement que
sur les questions géopolitiques,
géostratégiques, de renseignement
économique. Diplomatique, monsieur mon
ministre diplomatique.
Et moi, j'ai avant pas le droit de
désespérer.
J'ai toujours interdit à mes invités de
dire, il y en a un d'ailleurs un ancien
des renseignements qui a dit il y a
peut-être 3 4 ans, il a dit "Les jeunes,
barrez-vous, on est on est le le bateau
prend l'eau, ils sont tous en train de
jouer du violon pour garder la place à
la cantine." Je lui dis non, tu peux pas
dire ça ici. Maintenant, on a réévalué
la situation. Monsieur mon ministre, si
on se barre pour faire comme le général
de Gaulle parce que on en a marre, parce
queon est taxé jusqu'à la moelle, parce
que le la France est en train de virer
tout dit entre l'insécurité,
l'inflation, le bro,
pas de moelle épinière. Monsieur mon
ministre, j'incarne.
Qu'est-ce que vous me dites pour pas que
je me barre ? Et qu'est-ce que vous me
dites pour pas que je me barre et pour
pas que je me venge de ceux qui ont tué
mon pays ? Oui. Bon, on n'est pas encore
dans la vente d'êtet, hein. Euh bah,
d'abord vous avez beaucoup de caractère,
donc vous allez rester dans votre pays
et vous allez faire front comme on fait
tous quand on a des difficultés, on les
affronte, on les regarde en face et vous
allez prendre les problèmes les uns
après les autres et essayer de les
résoudre d'abord dans votre cercle
personnel, puis ensuite dans votre
cercle immédiat collectif, puis ensuite
dans le champ du commun. Euh il n'est
pas vrai que nous n'ayons pas le pouvoir
d'agir sur les événements. On peut un
déjà participer aux élections. Ça existe
les élections.
Bah oui, mais
on a un choix, il est vrai, qui serait
récit jour après jour.
Maich, on l'a brossé.
Oui, d'accord. Vous avez raison. Moi
aussi je je j'ai voté non en 2005 et je
ne suis toujours pas content la façon
dont on ne l'a, on nous l'a fait
derrière, hein. Si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire,
fistuler, c'est ça ? Non, je parle pas
comme ça. Je ne fais que penser.
C'est un terme médical he
hein. Voilà. Et donc mon avis est que
nous sommes une un peuple vaillant,
courageux et déterminé. Donc on a
inventé le général de Gaulle,
on a inventé euh Napoléon Bonaparte,
Louis XV. Euh, il y a des dingues. Il y
a on a inventé l'aluminium, la tour EFF,
l'hélicoptère, l'ascenseur, le ciment,
on a tout inventé. Donc faut arrêter. La
France,
elle est extraordinaire. Donc si les
gars, ils commencent à nous dire
"Excusez-moi, vous voulez vous barrer ?
Vous allez faire quoi ? Vous allez où ?"
Au Luxembourgance
dans le département des forêts.
[rires]
Non, mais je
vous voulez aller en Wallonie ?
C'est magnifique la Wallon. Je sais,
c'est magnifique mais
les woilons sont adorables.
Mais nous aimons les woilons d'ailleurs.
Et
et et leur bière est absolument
magnifique.
Il y a aussi la France. Voilà.
Et puis encore une fois, enfin quel dans
quel continent tu veux aller ? Enfin euh
il y a il y a un roman qui s'appelle
l'Europe le continent de la douceur.
Alors OK, c'est pas tous les jours
facile mais quand même tu as à peu près
un état de droit, tu as à peu près des
économies qui tournent, tu as un système
social qui arrive à peu près à te
protéger même s'il a des trous. Enfin,
mieux vaut essayer de réparer ça plutôt
que d'aller se barrer ailleurs. Enfin,
et je pense que la on a la capacité de
le faire et notamment en France encore
une fois si tu recrées de la production,
si tu recrées de l'industrie, tu recrées
des emplois qui sont plus qualifiés, tu
finances ton système social, il faudra
sans doute le réformer quand même, mais
un petit peu moins que si tu si tu fais
pas ça. Et donc, tu as un chemin devant
toi. Sais mais vous savez ce que je dis
moi aux jeunes qui viennent de me voir,
il a un paquet, il me téléphone, dit "Ah
monsieur Mondbour, ceci, cela". Je leur
dis monter les boîtes, c'est dur, vous
ne réussirez peut-être pas. Moi aussi ça
me j'ai échoué pour certaines entre
elles mais c'est pas grave.
Alors comme vous le savez, à chaque fois
ici je grossis le trait, je joue un rôle
un peu trop. Un peu trop.
C'est parce que vous êtes venu
aujourd'hui mon monsieur mon ministre et
que vous nous aviez manqué. Et
d'ailleurs, je je dédie cette émission à
un ami commun qui s'appelle Olivier
Marlex et et il me manque terriblement
et je lui dois un resto et je pourrais
jamais m'acquitter de de ça et tant pis.
Et on pense très très fort à lui. On
pense très très fort à lui. Et et
quand je dis voilà m'empêcher de me
venger, je grossis le trait. Vous
comprenez qu'il y a certains Français
qui veulent en venir aux mains.
Qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces
français ? qui ne le pourront pas, que
c'est un projet euh euh destructif et
que la seule chose euh qu'il est que
nous sommes capables de faire de ces
gens-là, c'est de leur montrer que nous
construisons et que c'est là qu' la joie
et et le bonheur du futur. Qu'est-ce que
je vous dise ? Non,
enfin quelque chose, c'est dit en des
termes quasiment romantiques, ça c'est
le côté Mais qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
avec ta ta colère ? Enfin, tu nourris la
colère pour créer quoi ? Rien.
Transforme cette énergie en un
engagement, en créant de la richesse
autour de toi, dans l'entrepreneuriat,
dans de l'engagement. Transforme cette
couleur en quelque chose positif. La
difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui, c'est
que cette colère, elle s'accumule parce
que tu n'as pas de projet. Tu n'as pas,
il y a personne qui t'a dessiné un
chemin en disant empreunte ça. Alors, il
y a il y a plein de petits chemins qui
feront ça, mais tous n'auront pas le
même. Mais il y a pas ce projet. À
partir du moment où tu énonces un
projet, moi je je vois bien cette colère
se transformer en énergie positive, en
engagement. En tous les cas, c'est la
conviction que j'ai. C'est facile
d'avoir de la colère. Vous
êtes très complémentaire tous. C'est
bien. Question internet. Monsieur
Mondbourg, vous dites que le programme
de Mélenchon mènerait la France à la
ruine parce qu'il ajoute des dépenses
publiques et de fiscalité. Mais vous
défendez depuis des années le
redressement productif, le
protectionnisme, la souveraineté
industrielle, la commande publique et la
relocalisation. Donc ma question est
simple. Pourquoi traitez-vous le
programme de la France insoumise comme
une dépense morte sans intégrer son
volet de réindustrialisation pour
intégration ? Est-ce est-ce une vraie
critique économique ou simplement le
refus politique d'une planification
industrielle plus radicale que la vôtre
? Ah non, c'est une vraie critique euh
économique. Euh quand vous créez 1
million d'agents publics, que vous créez
230 euh milliards de dépenses publiques
euh et que vous prélevez 80 milliards de
plus sur les entreprises, vous coulez
l'industrie. Donc vous réindustrialisez
rien du tout. Vous pouvez faire toutes
les planifications que vous voudrez, il
y aura plus d'entrepreneurs pour le
faire. Donc c'est n'importe quoi et
c'est cynique parce qu'ils le savent que
c'est n'importe quoi. Donc franchement
ce sont des gens qui sont absolument
toxiques pour la France et je peux vous
dire euh la rupture doit être vite
consommée avec les Français
intelligents, responsables. Il y en a
plein à gauche qui n'ont aucune raison
de mettre un bulletin aussi dangereux
dans les urnes. Il y a plein d'autres
solutions, hein, mais celle-là c'est la
pire.
Et franchement, on n pas besoin de ça en
ce moment. Voilà. Donc, ils font ça pour
se faire plaisir. Mais nous, il ils
savent très bien que c'est un programme
destructeur parce qu'on peut pas jouer
avec l'économie comme ça.
Question internet.
Top top la discussion des médicaments et
formulez correctement vos vos questions
les gars. Vous pensez que vous pensez
quoi du critical médecine acte européen
? le biotech act pointgation je trouve
que la biotechnologie est totalement
délaissée dans notre pays. C'est une
faute. Point d'interrogation la les
nouvelles thérapies cartes carte cells
crisp
on va faire comment ? Alors, bonne
question. Pour ce que j'en connais et
Olivier a une connaissance encore plus
approfondie que la mienne,
euh
toutes les innovations en biotechnologie
sont bloquées en Europe et partent aux
États-Unis parce que l'autorité de
reconnaissance des innovations est
rapide, créative,
intelligente et le chez nous, elle est
bureaucratique, lente et conservatrice.
conséquence, toutes les nouvelles
médecines et nouvelles technologies qui
ont été inventées, notamment les
biothèques,
sont en train de migrer aux États-Unis.
Toutes les start-ups ici meurent parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les autorisations et
donc elles vont se financer aux
États-Unis et avec notre épargne. Donc
elles vont enrichir les États-Unis. Donc
tout ça c'est le produit de la
bureaucratie européenne. Il est temps de
c'est comme les ARS, va falloir fermer
tout ça. Comme les autorités
indépendante de ceci et de cela qui sont
aussi indépendantes que ma belle- sœur
vis-à-vis du diacre. Tout ça c'est
affermé.
Il
est gentil le diacre. Pourtant
on parle de nucléaire. Vous connaissez
notre point de vue sur le nucléaire
selon la capacité à avoir la
disponibilité de l'uranium.
Je vais vous poser une question très
claire.
Là, on voit l'intégralité
du monde pouvoir se renucléariser.
Monsieur mon ministre, on en est où avec
les stocks d'uranium ? Monsieur mon
ministre, on en est où avec la
disponibilité pour nos 56 récteurs ?
Monsieur mon ministre, est-ce que le
nucléaire va y avoir une guerre pour
avoir de l'uranium comme il y a une
guerre pour avoir du pétrole ?
Alors, réponse, les ressources en
uranium sont finies.
Là, la volonté de construire des
réacteurs n'est pas infinie non plus.
Euh, les stocks d'uranium en France ne
sont pas en l'état menacé. 3, il y aura
évidemment un problème un moment ou un
autre sur le et c'est la raison pour
laquelle une nation nucléaire comme la
France a imaginé des réacteurs à neutron
rapide de fermeture du cycle qui ont
pour objectif de recycler indéfiniment
les déchets qui sont dans la piscine de
la ha qu'il faut vider. Donc je regrette
la décision qui a été prise par le
gouvernement sous-présidence Macron qui
a interrompu les recherches sur le
réacteur à street, je regrette même la
fermeture de Super Phenniix qui
permettait d'avoir ce qu'on a appelé le
réacteur de fermeture du cycle qui
permettait de recycler indéfiniment
ensuite les les
déchets nucléaires d'uranium qui avait
subi la réaction de fission dans les
réacteurs que nous exploitons.
Euh je dois dire que fermer à Astrid
pour autoriser euh une multitude de euh
start-up euh pour faire des mini
réacteurs à street dont on sait qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres modèles économiques
que celui d'être acheté par Microsoft ou
les patrons de data center américain, tu
es quand même une grave erreur
stratégique. J'approuve ce qu'a dit Yve
Brchet ici qui était mon haut
commissaire à l'énergie atomique lorsque
j'étais au gouvernement et j'aimerais
avoir l'opinion
avisé d'Olivier à la fois sur les
biothèques mais aussi sur ce que je
viens de dire. Est-ce que je me suis
trompé ou pas ? En tout cas c'est comme
ça qu'on on a imaginé et il y a très
longtemps que c imaginé c'était déjà
dans le plan Mesmer.
Je suis euh je [grognement] suis un des
ministres de l'industrie qui a s'est
battu pour allouer au projet Astrid au
commissariat d'énergie atomique et
alternative 600 millions et on les avait
versés. Donc tout ça était arrêté par
décision
incompréhensible. On n' jamais entendu
de compte-rendu
de d'exposer les motifs de cette
décision stupide.
Non mais Arnaud, tu avais pas envie de
débarquer avec une batte de baseball et
tout leur péter les genoux là.
Je suis à le le sujet là que vous avez
sur calme et rangé attention
sur le cycle nucléaire, c'est enfin le
stock. Je pense que Arnaud a a en tout
cas moi je je partage l'analyse qui est
faite par Arnaud mais là vous vous
placez déjà assez loin dans le temps. Il
y a un vrai sujet qui est plus court
pour nous c'est à col prix on va sortir
le MGAW des nouveaux EPR2 parce que la
France elle est prête à redévelopper du
nucléaire. Très bien. Les les les sur
les doublons là qui ont été faits, les
consultations publiques se sont bien
placées. Mais si on sort un MW à 100 120
ou 150 € le 150 € on va se faire avoir
par l'Europe de l'Est où on aura des
réacteurs sud-coréens sous licence
américaine qui vont pousser comme des
champignons et qui prendront la place
stratégique que la France a besoin de
prendre. C'est celui du fournisseur de
référence pour l'Europe au moins
l'Europe de l'Est d'électricité
décarbonée et pilotable par notre
nucléaire. Ça c'est notre atout
stratégique. Si on le garde, on a une
puissance de feu en Europe dans des
rapports de force absolument dingue. Tu
dis tu c'était pas une plaisanterie mais
si demain on met les interconnexions
entre la France et l'Allemagne en
maintenance administrative à 50 % de
leur puissance, les Allemands comme tu
le disais demain sont dans le noir. Et
donc on a un rapport de force. L'Europe
c'est pas que des bisounours, on a un
moyen de rapport de force. Si on le
perd, c'est gravissime. Donc ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui, c'est pas ton cycle,
c'est est-ce qu'on est capable de sortir
1 MW à 70 ou 80 € avec un design le PR2
qui pose quand même beaucoup de
questions à la fois aux ceux qui
observent et à ceux qui l'opèrent.
Alors, je veux compléter, c'est très
brillant et brillamment dit parce que
effectivement l'objectif de EDF, c'est
d'avoir des réacteurs à 70 € des
nouveaux réacteurs PR2 à 70 € le MW. Ça
suppose un financement public et une
forme d'investissement public, ce qui
est normal puisque c'est un outil
collectif. Et la Commission européenne
vient de retoquer le projet en disant
"C'est une aide d'État." Ah, la belle
affaire. Donc bah oui, c'est une aide
d'État. Donc là, il va falloir sortir
les battes de baseball contre la
Commission européenne. Là, pour le coup,
je suis d'accord parce que elle est en
train de tuer le projet économique des
EPR2 et comme on a un gouvernement une
espèce de de conciliation permanente
avec les les délires bureaucratiques
européens, on a un gouvernement qui
n'est pas à la hauteur pour mener le
combat face à à la Commission
européenne. Et donc là, moi j'ai un
problème sur ce sujet-là. On a un
deuxième sujet. [grognement] Les anglais
ont fait un travail de peignage avec
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui est
une autorité indépendante du pouvoir
politique
pour enlever tout ce qui était devenu
absolument inutile, absurde et
extrêmement coûteux. Ils ont fait un
travail avec euh
British Energy, c'est-à-dire
l'exploitant qui d'ailleurs via DEDF euh
si je ne m'abuse et euh l'autorité de
sûreté qui est indépendante disant bon
comment on fait pour que tout ce qu'on a
accumulé après Fukushima puis ceci puis
cela qui est une accumulation de mesures
de sûreté qui sont d'ailleurs des
doublons, des surplombs, des inutilités
sur quelques sujets, pas grand-chose,
rien dans le secteur critique qui puisse
diminuer les coûts. Et bien ça c'était
fait par le gouvernement anglais avec je
pense qu'il serait bon qu'on fasse la
même chose en France fait il a 10 ans
par
voilà et donc ils sont capables de faire
un nucléaire
moins cher donc faut qu'on fasse la même
chose mais là il faut qu'on mette tout
le monde autour de la table y compris
l'autorité de sûreté qui elle est est
une autorité de connaisseur d'experts et
aussi qui ont une intelligence
économique. Voilà. Donc il y a beaucoup
de choses à faire sur le sujet pour
gagner le combat de l'énergie bon marché
à horizon 2050. 2050 mais on sera tous
enfin c'est 2038 hein officiellement.
Question internet d'ailleurs qui qui
raisonne ce que ce qui raisonne bien.
Bonsoir. L'énergie et le sang de
l'économie de l'industrie. Quelle est la
vie le plan des invités suite au rapport
Shellenberger armant ?
ou conditions strictes pour
interconnexion électrique européenne,
impact intermittent espagnol et
allemande face à la Chine 12.500 TW.
Merci.
Bah c'est un bon rapport d' c'est à
cette commission d'enquête que j'ai
raconté j'ai j'ai fait l'autopsie de la
fermeture
de Fenheim et puis des 24 réacteurs que
le président François Hollande avait
promis de fermer.
Et tant que j'ai été là d'ailleurs, ils
n'ont pas fermé d'ailleurs après non
plus. Donc ça montrait bien que c'était
complètement absurde [grognement] et que
on était en train de s'autodétruire.
Si François Hollande se présente, vous
votez pour lui ?
Euh je n'ai je ne me place pas dans
cette hypothèse.
[rires]
Voilà hein.
Question internet que je prends au p au
pifomètre. Monsieur Mondbourg, bonsoir.
Qu'est-ce que la 6e République
devrait-elle être pour faire face au
défis à venir ? Point d'interrogation.
Ne devrait-on pas sélectionner nos
dirigeants encore plus scrupuleusement
qu'on le fait pour choisir nos
spaionutes ?
Euh c'est une réforme du financement des
partis politiques,
c'est une réforme des autorités
administratives indépendantes qui pulent
et qui euh c'est une remise à plat de la
relation Europe nation euh France euh
qui nous permet d'écarter euh les
décisions européennes qui porteraient
atteinte à l'intérêt national. Euh c'est
une réforme du système juridictionnel
qui est euh qui est aujourd'hui euh qui
est aujourd'hui euh euh [grognement]
navigue en portant atteint la
souveraineté nationale. C'est une
réforme des référendum d'initiative
populaire qu'il faudrait augmenter.
C'est une remise à plat de tout le
système des collectivités locales qui
est délirant, hein. Il va falloir quand
même qu'on remette de la cohérence et de
le le le territoire est suradministré
mais
il se sous-développe. C'est ça qu'on
voit.
Je vais je vais je vais lire
voilà ça fait beaucoup de choses à
faire.
Je vais je vais lire une question je
vais lire une question qui est qui est
en fait un commentaire mais je voudrais
vous faire réagir face à ce commentaire.
Montbourg plane toujours deux points. Il
cite les syndicats, les élus comme
solution. Trois points de suspension.
Quel nul ! Ce sont des guignoles qui
sont responsables de la de la situation
actuelle de la France. Syndicat élus
actuel sont à virer. Le code du travail
de 1945 interdisant la création d'autres
syndicats est à supprimer. Les élus
innombrables sont à diminuer
radicalement. diminution par deux des
députés et des sénateurs, suppression
des assemblées régionales et
départementales, fin de la
régionalisation européenne, retour au
préfet. Qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à
cette internaute là ?
Bah d'abord que euh quand j'entends ils
sont tous nuls, euh je crains une
faiblesse d'esprit
car il y a des gens brillants et des
gens idiots partout. Voilà. Voyez,
[grognement] il y a il y a une
concentration dans dans l'élite
française de gens très intelligents qui
sont capables de faire ensemble beaucoup
de conneries, si vous passez
l'expression. Pardonnez-moi de parler
comme ça. Bon, donc je vais vous dire
quand j'entends que il faut couper,
tailler et cetera, tout ça, on sait que
ça ne se fera pas. Donc ce qui est je
crois qu'il faudrait revenir à euh une
for il y a des choses intelligentes dans
ce qui a été dit. le retour au préfet
par exemple, moi je suis pour que les
permis de construire euh en période de
crise de logement reviennent au préfet
qu'on en dépossède les mers. Pourquoi ?
Parce que les maires de gauche ne
veulent pas de gens riches, les maires
de droite ne veulent pas de gens pauvres
et les écologistes, les maires
écologistes, ils veulent personne. Donc
comme ça, vous avez compris pourquoi une
crise du logement en France, hein.
Voilà. Puis vous avez les associations
qui se mettent dessus, les recours, on
en parle. Vous savez que les promoteurs,
je ne défends pas les promoteurs mais
c'est intéressant parce c'est un
symptôme. Dans les promoteurs, il y a
une ligne des intéressements de tous les
recours. Euh vous n'avez pas un
promoteur qui a pas 100 millions par an
de frais pour euh acheter euh la paix
euh juridictionnelle. Donc c'est
délirant. Donc en fait on a fait un
c'est un business d'attaquer les permis
de construire, donc de bloquer la
construction de logement. Il y a des
gens qui vont travailler et qui sont
dans leur voiture ou qui vont au
camping, j'en connais hein,
des ouvriers he des employés, des gens
qui voilà, ils peuvent pas. Donc moi, je
voudrais dire que on a des problèmes
[grognement] à résoudre qui n'ont jamais
été résolus. Ils ont été mis sous la
table. Donc c'est pas en rebespérisant
la politique tout couper la tête de tout
le monde qu'on y arrivera. Et moi je
suis désolé, j'ai rencontrer des
syndicalistes qui ont un sens de
l'intérêt général, des patrons qui ont
un sens de la patrie extraordinaire,
des élus qui heureusement sont là parce
qu'ils tiennent le territoire et
s'occupent des gens. Excusez-moi. Un élu
pour moi c'est un administrateur
bénévole. He d'ailleurs je j'incite
cette personne
j'incite cette personne à se présenter
aux élections puis on verra si elle
continuera à dire ce qu'elle dit.
Présentez-vous, monsieur, et on verra
parce que ça, il faut l'avoir fait. Moi,
je l'ai fait 20 ans, j'en ai eu marre,
voyez. Donc maintenant, ça me permet
d'être un tout petit peu plus comment
dire détendu et heureux dans ma vie.
Mais je vous assure que vous devriez le
faire. Je pense que vous changeriez de
perspective.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que vous
aimeriez aborder ou ou discuter avec nos
internautes ? Est-ce qu'il y a un truc
qui vous tient à cœur ? Olivier Arnaud,
je vous laisse choisir et puis après on
passe à la question signature de notre
émission pour clôturer cette émission.
Je vous laisse réfléchir une minute.
Soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on a besoin de
vous. Partagez cette interview sur tous
les réseaux. Partagez sur Twitter, sur
Facebook. Partagez, partagez,
soutenez-nous sur Tipi parce que grâce à
vous, on peut maintenir un espace libre
pour l'instant.
Olivier, un sujet. Euh [grognement] vous
avez abordé beaucoup de sujets
politiques pour moi pour réussir à faire
toutes ces transformations. Et quelle
que soit notre conviction, il faut qu'on
mette un peu de charbon dans la machine,
faut qu'on reproduise, faut qu'on
remette un peu de croissance dans ce
pays et on a plein de potentiels. Il y a
un sujet qu'on a pas abordé, donc je je
descends un peu dans dans la machinerie,
c'est la question de notre fiscalité.
Aujourd'hui, on a une fiscalité de la
production où on est en Europe celui qui
taxe plus la fiscal de la production et
on est le 4e meilleur sur les taux les
plus bas en moyenne de TVA par exemple
sur la consommation. Donc on a fait
vraiment un choix et ça c'est un choix
collectif qu'il faut dénoncer. Il faut
expliquer pourquoi on a fait le choix
d'une économie de consommation
pas cher. On vente le pouvoir d'achat et
finalement on va acheter du produit
chinois. on travaille plus en France et
infiné, on aura même plus les salaires
pour se payer des produits chinois.
Enfin, tu tu es dans ce dans ce cycle
là. Donc là, on a un sujet qu'on a pas
abordé, c'est comment tu rééquilibres
euh la question de la fiscalité et
comment tu l'expliques parce que
derrière il y a une vraie question de
pouvoir d'achat et donc c'est pas aussi
simple que ça. Ça, c'est un vrai sujet.
On est passé à côté.
Monsieur mon ministre. Alors Olivier
Luim m'enlève de la bouche le sujet
parce que là je vais vous dire on se
focalise sur les problèmes d'inégalité
hein qui qui sont réels. Il y a les
problèmes d'inégalité mais aussi la
redistribution qui fonctionne en en
corrigeant les inégalités. Mais le vrai
sujet c'est l'arbitrage consommateur
producteur. On n jamais fait ces
choix-là. Conséquence ben on est en
liquette hein. Si je
en guille
en guille en guille en loc sur le plan
productif. Puis un autre sujet qu'on
pourrait évoquer, c'est celui de la
recherche et de l'innovation. Tu as
parlé tu as parlé des bioteches. Euh on
a un objectif collectif de 3 % de du
PIB, hein. C'est l'objectif miracle à
mettre dans la recherche et dans
l'innovation. On n'y est pas, on est
très loin. Là aussi, c'est des choix de
où est-ce que tu mets ton argent, hein,
notre argent collectif. Ça c'est pour
moi un deuxième grand sujet. On est tous
d'accord sur l'objectif. Comment est-ce
qu'on se met véritablement en route pour
le réaliser ? Ça c'est encore un autre
sujet mais là on n'est plus dans des
mesures techniques je dirais sur
lesquelles tout le monde est d'accord.
On est sur des choix de société des
débats profonds qu'on doit avoir pour
trancher où est-ce qu'on veut aller.
Le CICE non on parle un peu ou c'est
trop c milliards ?
Bah si on peut pas de toute façon le
CICE c'était quoi ? C'était pour
compenser la fiscalité sur la
production. c'est avant même d'avoir
commencé à produire euh on est on est
euh taxé. C'est ça l'impôt de
production. Euh la différence avec un
impôt sur le revenu du capital qui est
l'impôt sur les sociétés, c'est que
c'est un solde. C'est une fois qu'on a
travaillé, qu'on a dégagé un revenu
qu'on paye. Euh donc moi, j'aurais
préféré que euh on baisse les impôts de
production, on augmente l'impôt sur les
sociétés parce que c'est un impôt sur le
revenu. C'est normal ça que le revenu il
cotise. Le CCE c'était une technique
fiscale pour gagner un an de budgétaire
mais globalement ça s'est terminé en
baisse de charge. Moi ça me choque pas
honnêtement. aujourd'hui notamment sur
les hauts salaires, tu les ingénieurs en
France ne sont compétitifs que parce
qu'il y a le cire. C'est c'est dingue
parce que et et comparé à des à d'autres
fiscalités, OK, on peut rêver de taxer
au maximum, on vit dans un monde qui est
réel, celui d'une concurrence même
intraeuropéenne avec l'ingénieur
allemand et cetera. Donc moi je le CIC
pour appuyer pour appuyer ce que dit
Olivier puisque c'est moi qui mis en
œuvre le CICE euh sur l'injonction ou la
suggestion de Louis Galois dans son
fameux rapport sur la compétitivité de
la France, c'est qu'en fait on a encore
après tout ce qui a été fait en
politique de l'offre, on a encore un
écart d'une cinquantaine de milliards
défavorable par rapport à l'Allemagne.
Euh et l'Allemagne est en difficulté.
Donc vous voyez que on a encore du
travail à faire pour arriver à nous
mettre, j'allais dire [grognement] à
l'unisson
dans la compétition.
On pourra pas s'aligner sur la Chine ou
sur des pays asiatiques, mais au moins
utilisons les pays européens comme des
pays de référence. Je rappelle que
l'Italie a un excédent commercial de 60
milliards et que l'Allemagne un excédent
commercial de plus de 100 milliards sans
quand c'est pas 200 les bonnes années.
Ils sont en Europe et ils ont les mêmes
directives européennes que nous. Donc on
peut beaucoup critiquer l'Europe mais
aussi il faut qu'on balaye un peu devant
chez nous avant.
Trois livres Arnaud.
Trois livres
à conseiller à notre communauté.
Alors je conseille le livre
de ce journaliste du Guardian Luc
Harding Collusion. Il a repris les les
dossiers de l'ancien agent du MI6 qui
était en poste à Moscou et qui montre la
collusion entre Vladimir Poutine et
Donald Trump et qui explique son
comportement diplomatique. C'est moi
j'aurais mis corruption mais en vérité
c'est le titre collusion.
Ça date de quelle année ce bouquin ?
Ça date de 2000
2017 18 19 par là hein avant le premier
mandat je crois. Un deuxème livre
euh un 2è livre le livre d'Aquilino
Morel euh qui a été le conseiller
spécial de Hollande qui a fait une
analyse extraordinairement brillante sur
le wisme. Qui s'aime le wisme récolte le
trumpisme. Très bon. J'ai oublié le
titre du livre mais c'est son dernier
livre à lire d'urgence.
Et le troisème ?
Alors le 3è
je vais vous dire que
le livre de Bruno Lemire
euh je l'ai pas lu, je peux pas en
parler. Euh je ne je je peux donc encore
moins le conseiller euh mais euh
ça me reviendra après qu'Olivier est
sorti ses deux premiers. [rires]
On est obligé de rester sur des livres
parce que ah
on peut faire un film ou une musique
hein.
OK. alors un livre Le continent de la
douceur, Aurélien, j'ai oublié son nom,
mais qui nous rappelle quand même que on
vit dans un monde européen
qui a gagné beaucoup de choses en
humanisme, en respect et cetera et que
ça, il faut pas l'oublier. C'est bien de
faire de vouloir dégager, de vouloir
partir mais on a
se faire respecter.
Mais j'ai pas dit le contraire. Après
dedans tout n'est pas parfait. Il y a du
boulot à faire. Je suis le premier à le
reconnaître. On en a parlé pendant 2
heures mais déjà le deuxième c'est une
pièce de théâtre ça s'appelle made in
France pour ceux pour qui la production
est étrangère parce que il y a 10 % des
Français qui travaillent dans
l'industrie. Donc les 90 % tous n'ont
pas la chance d'aller voir une usine et
cetera. Mais pour comprendre un peu les
rapports de force, les jeux humains à
l'intérieur, une superbe pièce de
théâtre.
[grognement]
Et puis le troisème est quelque chose si
vous avez des insomnies mais je
recommande quand même de le lire, c'est
le rapport du haut commissariat au plan
et à la stratégie sur le fait que dans
la plupart de nos secteurs, même dans la
totalité de nos secteurs économiques, la
Chine est capable de produire à 30 ou 40
% de moins que l'Europe en général.
C'est le rouleau compresseur. Ça c'est
un peu technique mais c'est une prise de
conscience sur le rapport de force qu'on
qui est en train de se jouer avec une
parole en plus officielle euh
officialisé je dirais. Voilà, ça ce
serait les trois les trois éléments que
je recommanderais.
Arnaud le 3è.
Alors le trisème je l'avais cité c'était
le livre d'Olivier Lei qui était son
rapport hein. Réindustrialisons
le défi d'une génération. Euh je pense
que ce livre chez Duna er
non chez les déviations petite édition.
Très bien. Et ben voilà
la dernière question c'est un conseil,
c'est pas une question c'est laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations. Une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable. On commence par Olivier
et on finit par mon ministre.
Oh, ça c'est une question,
crois en tes valeurs, crois en toi,
quelque chose comme ça. On a des vraies
valeurs en Europe, en France, avec
l'histoire de notre pays, mais qui a
aussi été mêlé avec celle des autres
nations européennes. Sois-en fier. On a
une question de fierté de qui on est euh
qui pour moi est euh c'est tellement
beau l'histoire, c'est on a tellement de
potentiel, on a tellement de richesse.
Euh soyons fiers de ce que on a fait et
euh soyons fiers de ce qu'on peut faire.
Voilà.
Conseil de monsieur mon ministre.
La France est une personne et c'est un
être aimé.
On la regarde parfois dans son sommeil
comme si elle sommeillait à côté et on
voit à la fois son point de noirceur,
vous en avez beaucoup parlé ou son point
d'éclat. Nous avons essayé d'en parler
et il faut l'aimer comme une personne.
Et si on l'aime, d'abord on lui
pardonne. Deuxièmement, on vit pour
elle, on vibre pour elle. Et la vie
individuelle prend un sens parce que il
appartient à quelque chose de beaucoup
plus grand. Et pour ça, il faut relire
les pages de mémoire de guerre du
général de Gaulle quand il raconte qu'il
était face à l'océan, qu'il allait
devoir vider à la cuillère. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait devant l'impossible à
réaliser,
on réalise et ben ça c'est l'engagement
de chacun pour notre pays à sa manière,
selon ses valeurs, ses croyances et
surtout avec un espoir qui est commun.
toujours sauver la mère patrie messieur
merci
merci à toi
merci pour l'invitation et puis surtout
pour ce dialogue si amical et
sympathique. Ok.
[musique]